WELCOME TO THE JOINT HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR. FOUR WE BEGAN OUR
HEARING I WANT TO GO OVER A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS DUE TO THE
ONGOING. DEMAGOGUERY ONE IN THE
ROOM TODAY MUST WEAR FACE
COVERING AT ALL TIMES AND
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
THE ROOM AND IN THE REST OF THE
BUILDING. SECOND THE STRUCTURE
OF THE PANEL IS AS FOLLOWS WE
WILL HEAR FROM FOUR PANELISTS
THEN OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS. THEN HERE ARE LAST
FOUR PANELISTS AND ALLOW
QUESTIONS BEFORE TRANSITIONING
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PUBLIC
COMMENT CALL IN NUMBER IS.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE NUMBER. IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. THE
NUMBER OF REPEAT IT ONE MORE
TIME 1-877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR
COMPUTER SCREEN. I ASK THAT
THOSE CALLING TO PLEASE STATE
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION AND KEEP
COMMENTS ON THE TOPIC. FOR THOSE
CALLING THEN PLEASE SILENCE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE INCLUDING
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND ALL OF YOUR SMART
DEVICES IF YOU'RE HAVING A
PROBLEM WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN ALSO CALL THE
COMMITTEE. UP AT MY STAFF OR MY
STAFF AND THERE WILL BE SOMEONE
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME
YOU TO OUR FIRST INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THIS SESSION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US I
BECAME CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR. THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR IS ONE THAT I'M
INTIMATELY AWARE OF HAVING
FOUNDED A NONPROFIT MYSELF. IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT I NOW HAVE
THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING. AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS A BACKGROUND IN
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR I KNOW JUST
HOW CHALLENGING IT IS TO OPERATE
A NONPROFIT LET ALONE OPERATING
ONE DURING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN CHALLENGING FOR ALL. WE
HAVE HEARD STORIES OF HOW THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTORS HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED AND FOR THE MOST
PART HOW THE SECTORS HAVE
NAVIGATED CHALLENGES. ONE STORY
THAT IS NOT HEARD AS OFTEN BUT
ONE THAT WE NEED TO ELEVATE AND
UNDERSTAND IS THAT OF NON
PROFITS NONPROFITS ARE AT THE
CENTER OF OUR COMMUNITIES THEY
WORK AROUND THE CLOCK TO SUPPORT
THE NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES
THEY HELP HUNGRY FAMILIES WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO PURCHASE FOOD
ASSIST THOSE WHO ARE LOOKING FOR
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT OUR OWN HOUSE
RESIDENTS. AND SO MUCH MORE OUR
NEEDS WOULD GO ONE MET IF IT
WEREN'T FOR NONPROFITS WHO
CONTINUOUSLY STEP UP. NONPROFITS
OFTEN OPERATE BEHIND THE SCENES
BUT I CANNOT EMPHASIZE THIS
ENOUGH WE WOULD NOT BE WHERE WE
ARE NOW WITHOUT THEM. AS THEIR
WORK CONTINUED ON THE FRONT
LINES THEY WERE CONTINUOUSLY
LEFT BEHIND THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. I ALONG WITH TWENTY
NINE OTHER MEMBERS WROTE A
LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR TO ENSURE
THAT FUNDING TO NONPROFITS WERE
PROVIDED IN THEIR TIME OF NEED.
SINCE NONPROFITS ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR COMMUNITIES IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WE PROVIDE THEM
WITH THE FUNDS AND SUPPORT.
THEIR NEEDS SO THEY CAN WEATHER
ANY FUTURE STORMS. THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE US WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM NONPROFIT LEADERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE HOPE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE PANDEMIC HAS
AFFECTED THEIR OPERATIONS AND
HOW THEY HAVE NAVIGATED
CHALLENGES. WHILE THE PANDEMIC
HAS BEEN CHALLENGING IT'S ALSO
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT AND
BETTER PREPARE OUR NON PROFITS
FOR FUTURE EMERGENCIES. I WILL
NOW TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR LEE
MON. OF THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR TO SHARE A FEW
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT CHAIR RIVAS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP- AND THANK
YOU TO BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE FOR THIS JOINT HEARING I
KNOW THAT WHEN OUR NONPROFIT
SELECT COMMITTEE STARTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THIS WAS THE
ULTIMATE VISION TO HAVE JOINT
HEARINGS AND TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY COLLABORATIVELY
IN EACH HOUSE- TO BE ABLE TO
UPLIFT THE ISSUES FACING OUR
NONPROFITS. AND IN PARTICULAR TO
YOU KNOW JEREMY THAT'S AND THE
TEAM FOR A THIRTEEN FOR
ORGANIZING THIS. HEARING TO TALK
ABOUT THE ROLE THAT NONPROFITS
HAVE PLAYED DURING THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY THAT WE'VE BEEN
LIVING. THANK YOU TO THE
NONPROFIT FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY- YOU HAVE STEPPED UP TIME
AND TIME AGAIN- YOU WE ARE VERY
THANKFUL TO YOU FOR COMMITTING
TO ARE WORKING WITH OUR
FAMILIES- TO BEING ON THE FRONT
LINES TO KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. AND TO ADJUSTING YOUR
MISSION BUT IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES THRIVE
DURING THIS EMERGENCY. THAT'S A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR IS TO THE STATE WE ALSO
KNOW AND LIVE HOW IMPORTANT THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR IS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES EACH OF IT MEMBERS
HERE HAS AN EXPERIENCE WITH
NONPROFITS IN THE DISTRICT- WE
KNOW THE VALUE THEY BRING TO
ENHANCING THE QUALITYOF LIFE.
TO KEEPING COMMUNITY SAFE I INTO
HELPING US REACH OUR GOALS IN
GOVERNMENT ALONE WE CANNOT DO
IT- JUST SIMPLY BY BY FOCUSING
ON GOVERNMENT ALONE WE LOOK TO
THESE NONPROFITS AS PARTNERS TO
HELP US ACHIEVE OUR GOALS- AND
PROJECT OUR VALUES SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING- ON HOW THE
STATE CAN BE A PARTNER. TO
NONPROFITS WERE STEPPING UP
DURING PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES
THANK YOU CHAIR. THANK OU
SENATOR FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN
YOUR LEADERSHIP- EVEN WHEN YOU
WERE SERVING IN THE ASSEMBLY. SO
THANK YOU. AB NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM ANY MEMBERS THAT WANT TO
SPEAK. OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON. LET ME DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE COMES- SEND- OF FROM
WHERE. SANTA BARBARA BECAUSE HE
WAS HERE PERSONAL PLEASE OUT OF
FOR HIM OKAY THANK YOU. HI I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK A SENATOR
LOW MOAN- FOR HER EARLY EFFORTS
TO KICK THIS OFF AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS FOR
CONTINUING THIS EFFORT AND
TAKING OVER AS A CENTER OF THE
MALL MOVED OVER TO THE SENATE-
THEY HAVE ALREADY EXPRESSED ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT- I CERTAINLY
FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT- WITH REGARD
TO NONPROFIT SO I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO POINT OUT- TWO THINGS-
AND THAT IS. IF IT IN IN THE
COMMUNITY SAID I'VE REPRESENTED
IN SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTY. CONSISTENTLY IF I'M
LOOKING FOR THE BEST MOST LIKE
MINDED PEOPLE ON THE CONTRARY
THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY CARE
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY. I TURN TO
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR THAT'S
WHERE YOU FIND THOSE PEOPLE THEY
GENUINELY THINK ABOUT COMMUNITY.
NOT JUST THE INDIVIDUAL AND WE
HAVE UNFORTUNATELY IN AMERICA
TODAY- WE'VE HAVE TOO MANY
PEOPLE OF LOS THAT IMPORTANT
SENSE OF LOOKING OUT FOR THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY AND INSTEAD. TOO
MUCH LOOKING OUT SPECIFICALLY
FOR THEMSELVES AND SO TO
EVERYBODY IN THE NONPROFIT
WORLD- I WANT TO TAKE MY HAT OFF
AND SAY THANK YOU FOR SORT OF
REPRESENTING. THAT VERY
IMPORTANT- ELEMENTARY AND
HOLDING OUR COMMUNITIES
TOGETHER- AND THE SECOND THING
IS THAT I WAS JUST ON THE PHONE
WITH A- LINDA BROWN TREASURE
FROM THE- RUST FUND OF THE
HOUSING TRUST FUNDED. IN THERE
THERE'S A PERSON THAT SERVE JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE THIRTY YEARS-
SHE'S BEEN DEDICATED TO TRYING
TO COME UP WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE. THEY GET IT
THEY GET IT RIGHT TODAY FOR
EXAMPLE SHE SAYING IT WE DON'T
WANT TO DO MARKET RATE HOUSING.
WE WANT TO DO THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SO THE OTHER ROLE
THAT YOU NON PROFITS TO ISSUE
KEEP US ON TRACK IN TERMS OF
POLICY. YOU HELP US KNOW WHAT IT
IS THAT REALLY NEEDS TO HAPPEN
ON THE GROUND- TO MAKE GOOD
POLICY FOR EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA SO. THOSE TWO THINGS
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AND I'M
HAPPY TO TURN IT BACK OVER TO
THE CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
HEARING TODAY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- NEXT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES- SUMMER BENNETT BUT
MOST OF ALL WHEN I THINK OF THE
TWO CHAIRS- CHAIRWOMAN RIVAS AND
ALSO SENATOR LIMÓN FOR WIND-
GALVANIZING ENERGIZING THIS
CONVERSATION. I ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE ECHO- THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE WITH RESPECT TO
WIND- WHEN- SENATOR LIMON WAS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN LET ALONE AND SHE
WANTED TO SPEAK IT IS ORGANIZED
IN THIS NONPROFIT- SELECT
COMMITTEE IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL- BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE VOICES OF
NONPROFITS WERE ELEVATED. AND
HOW DO WE ELEVATE THAT BUT HAVE
A SELECT COMMITTEE TO FOCUS ON
THAT KIND OF WORK THIS WORK IS
VERY VITAL. IS VERY VITAL TO THE
NONPROFIT WHICH I REPRESENT- IN
THE WATTS COMPTON MY ENTIRE
DISTRICT THE SIX BOARDS THERE'S
A CONFLICT OF CALIFORNIA THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINE. DEALING WITH OF THIS
PANDEMIC. AND ALSO WHAT KEEPS UP
US UP AT NIGHT IS THAT- THERE'S
SO MANY PEOPLE THERE STILL HAVE
NOT BEEN VACCINATED IS THE DOOR
TO DOOR CAMPAIGN WITH THESE
NONPROFITS WHO I PARTNER WITH.
TO GO DOOR TO DOOR I'M TALKING
ABOUT WHY THIS- THE VACCINE IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND.
IMPORTANT IS THOSE NONPROFITS
WHO HELPED ME- FEET FIFTEEN
HUNDRED- FAMILIES IN THE MID OF
NOT HAVING FOOD IN A MIX OF THIS
PANDEMIC. IS THOSE NONPROFIT WHO
DO WORK THAT OTHER PEOPLE WON'T
DO IS THOSE NONPROFIT WHO STEP
IN ABSOLUTELY STAND IN THE GAP
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ABSOLUTELY
NEED THE SERVICES AS THOSE NOT
PROPERTY. WHO ARE TROUBLING IS
AROUND EDUCATION PUBLIC SAFETY
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ALSO
JOB IS THOSE NONPROFITS. THAT I
NEED TO HAVE A VOICE- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS THOSE
NONPROFIT. WHOSE TO HAVE STOOD
IN THE GAP FOR PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO HAVE NO BROADBAND
SERVICE WHO STEPPED UP TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAD BROADBAND
SERVICE I WANNA THINK W. O. C.
A. C. A. WHICH IS THE WATTS
LABOR COMMUNITY ACTION. WHO
STOOD IN THE GAP FOR PEOPLE AND
AS A RESULT OF STANDING IN THE
GAP OF PEOPLE THEY WERE
DISCONNECTED. BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. AND
SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT NONPROFIT- GET CONNECTED SO
THEY CAN PROVIDE THE KIND OF
SERVICES BROADBAND SERVICES.
THAT THE PEOPLE NEED- IN MY
DISTRICT AND SO I THINK THIS IS
A VERY TIMELY. I'M CONVERSATION
AND ONE AGAIN THANK BOTH THE
CHAIRS ARE COMING TOGETHER TO
ELEVATE THE VOICES OF THESE
NONPROFIT THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY
VITAL AND CRITICAL. TO
CALIFORNIA'S FABRICS ARE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEXT SENATOR
PACKARD. I THANK YOU I ALSO WANT
TO. THANK MY BOTH OF OUR CHAIRS
THAT SURELY WON'T ENSURE
REVISED. FOR THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION IT'S A LOT OF MY
HEART. LIES IN THE NONPROFIT.
SECTOR SPENT TWENTY YEARS ITH
FULL CIRCLE DURING GRANT MAKING
A PARTNERING WITH NONPROFITS.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON-
ELOQUENTLY STATED WE SAW THE
NONPROFITS COMMUNITY STEP UP IN
A HUGE WAY IN THIS PANDEMIC AND
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
HEARING TODAY. THANKS SO WE ARE
READY TO START WITH OUR FIRST
PANEL OUR FIRST PANEL WILL BE
HEARING FROM FOR NONPROFIT
LEADERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE-
AND THEIR EXPERIENCES. WITH
COVERT NINETEEN AND RESPONSE ON
THE GROUND UP. SO IT'S VERY
EXCITING FOR ME TO. START WITH
MAHDI SELA MORALIS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE. UNITED FOR A
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY BECAUSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT WILL BE USED
FOR THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- TO THE ASSEMBLY CHAIRWOMAN
READ THAT THEN SENATE CHAIRWOMAN
LEAP ON BOARD IT'S REALLY
HISTORIC. A DATE TO HAVE THE
FIRST JOINT HEARING OF THE FLOOD
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES FOR-
SHARING HOW DIRECTLY CONNECTED
TO YOU YOU ARE YOU HAVE BEEN- TO
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR. MY NAME IS
MAHDI SALEM WHAT I LISTEN. AND I
. THE HONOR OF SERVING AS EXEC
DIRECTOR OF COST IN INSURANCE
SANTA BARBARA. AND ALSO AS CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS. OF BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND THAT I WANT TO
SHARE BRIEFLY THAT OUR OUR BOARD
REPRESENTS THE- HAVE
REPRESENTATION FROM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IS MAJORITY PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE- MY WANT TO SHARE JUST
A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AYE I MOVE FROM
CONTENT TO VENTURA COUNTY WHEN I
WAS FOUR- BUT STILL HAVE FAMILY
THERE ARE SO. PROFIT IT'S REALLY
CONNECTED US THROUGH THE WHOLE-
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE STATE AND
WE'RE HERE TO SERVE THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR AND TO BE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU SO
FIRST OF ALL I WANTED TO TAKE
THE TIME TO JUST SHARE SOME
BRIEF QUICK HIGHLIGHTS ABOUT HOW
CRITICAL THE NONPROFIT SECTOR IF
THE CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVELY WE
PROVIDE ABOUT 32% OF MEDICAL
SERVICES SO THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE
THE CIVIC EXAMPLE AS WITH DAD
ABOUT HOW CRITICAL THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN NONPROFITS
AND- CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IS AT
ALL LEVELS. OF I WANT TO SHARE
IN TERMS OF BEING AN IMPORTANT
KEY EMPLOYER THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR IS THE FOURTH LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN CALIFORNIA AND IS A
LEADER IS LEADING THE WAY IN
TERMS OF DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION ON ITS STAFF 63% OF
THE WORKFORCE OF NONPROFITS IS
OUR WOMEN ARE 29% OF NONPROFIT
LEADERSHIP ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR
COMPARED 212% IN THE GENERAL
WORKFORCE. AND IN TURN THE BOARD
LEADERSHIP 56% OF THE NONPROFIT
BOARDS INCLUDE WOMEN AND 27% ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR COMPARED 216% IN
THE FOR PROFIT SECTOR SO THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR IS INCLUSIVE.
AND A KEY EMPLOYER IN THE STATE.
WE CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY SO NONPROFIT TO BRING IN
AS AN EXAMPLE ONE EXAMPLE MORE
THAN FORTY BILLION INTO
CALIFORNIA FROM OUT OF STATE.
AND WE GENERATE 15% OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PROJECT. I WANT
TO MOVE CLOSER TO HOME IN TERMS
OF SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW
NONPROFIT THAT STEPPED UP DURING
THE PANDEMIC TRYING FROM OUR OUR
PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE THAT- AS
NONPROFIT BECAUSE IN THE VENTURA
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY AREA- FIRST
IN TERMS OF VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
REALLY ON THE ON THE MARGINS AND
UNDERSERVED OF COURSE INCREASED
DEMAND. TWO EXAMPLES YOU. KNOW
YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS
HOW MENTAL HEALTH IS A TOP
PRIORITY DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
CONTINUE TO ORGANIZE YOUTH- FOR
A COLLECTIVE VOICE HELLO BUT YOU
WERE ABLE TO WIN- INCREASED-
COUNSELORS SO IMPORTANT TO THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. ESPECIALLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS COVE IT BROUGHT TO THE
FOREFRONT THAT THEY ARE BARRED.
THEY ARE LOCKED OUT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
DURING OF THE PANDEMIC.
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WERE THE
HARDEST HIT BY JOB LOSS
IMMIGRANT WOMEN IN PARTICULAR
WERE THE HARDEST HIT. AND
WORKING WITH OTHER NONPROFITS WE
LAUNCHED- OFFICIALLY AS A
NONPROFIT ITSELF THE EIGHT OH
FIVE IN DOCUSIGN WHICH
DISTRIBUTED OVER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN DIRECT RELIEF
FINANCIAL RELIEF. TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO LOST
THEIR JOB AND WORK IN ELIGIBLE
TO CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. AND WE'RE WORKING
WITH OTHER A NONPROFIT STATEWIDE
TO FIX THAT IN JUSTICE AND. LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT IN THAT.
ARE KEEPING THEM. A LOT AND HOW
STEP UP SO ADDS IN ORDER. AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION. WE HELP
TO KEEP DEMOCRACY ALIVE DURING
THE PANDEMIC WHEN EVERYTHING WAS
SHUT DOWN INCLUDING PUBLIC
MEETINGS PHYSICALLY. WE TAUGHT
YOUTH YOUNG ADULTS AND AN ADULT
HOW DO YOU USE THEM HOW TO OF
WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT THE CITY
COUNCIL THE COUNTY SUPERVISOR AT
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. TO SPEAK
UP EVEN DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS. OF NONPROFITS
CONTINUING TO STEP BEYOND THEIR
MISSION. IN OUR CASE WE ARE IN
ORGANIZING AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND YET WE STEPPED
UP TO DO DIRECT SERVICE. TO HELP
PEOPLE SIGN UP FOR THE VACCINE.
AND YOU KNOW GET TO- THE
NECESSARY. RESOURCES THEY NEED
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MADI SALA
I'M NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
CARMEN IDEA REPRESENTING AND
CONCEAL OF STOCKTON. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS GOVERNMENT BY THE END
OF THE CHIEF OF STAFF AT
CONSIGLIO CALIFORNIA ECHO
STUDIOS AND NONPROFIT MULTI
SERVICE AGENCY CURRENTLY SERVING
SAN JOAQUIN STANISLAUS AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES. WITH A
MISSION TO UP LIFT AND ADVOCATE
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES BY
PROVIDING CRITICAL SERVICES AND
RESOURCES WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
OUR EXPERIENCE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
SERVING OUR COMMUNITY FOR OVER
FIFTY FOUR YEARS AND THE
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED. THAT
WE ARE A TRUSTED RESOURCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND A MESSENGER AND WE
ARE ALSO ESSENTIAL FIRST
RESPONDERS TO OUR COMMUNITY. OUR
ORGANIZATION HAD TO ACT QUICKLY
AND DEVISING STRATEGIZE AND
CREATE A PLAN OF ACTION ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES
TO. OUR CLIENTS. AND OUR
COMMUNITY. WE REALIZE QUICKLY
THAT WE HAD TO TAKE THE
RESOURCES OUT INTO OUR COMMUNITY
AND THAT WE COULDN'T WAIT FOR
OUR MEMBERS TO COME TO US THE
FIRST THING WE HAD TO DO WAS TO
ADDRESS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WE
HAVE MOVE SOME OF OUR SERVICES-
FOR TO DIGITAL. AND SO WE HAD TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE
WERE ABLE TO ACCESS THAT'S WHAT
WE HAD TO DO WAS WE HAD TO HELP
CREATE EMAIL ADDRESSES HOW TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION ON HOW TO
ACCESS GOOGLE MEETS AND ZUNE
MEETINGS- TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY WAS ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO ACCESS THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED IT WE
ALSO DISTRIBUTED LAPTOPS AND
ALSO SENT OUT MOBILE HOT SPOTS.
TO AREAS THAT WERE NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITY WE ALSO LED TO VARIOUS
GRASSROOTS EFFORTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY- BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION. ON COULD NINETEEN
AND RESOURCES IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH MANY LOCAL NONPROFITS. THE
FIRST THING THAT WE DID WE
ORGANIZED MANY POP UP. VACCINE
AND TESTING CLINICS- AT IT AT
OUR OFFICES AT LOCAL GROCERY
STORES AT PLACES OF WORK. OUT
LOCAL RANCHES- OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOLS WE ACTUALLY TOOK THE
RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE- AND
MAKE THEM MORE THEY NEEDED AND-
ALSO AT THE TIME THAT THEY
NEEDED WE ENSURED THAT THESE
CLINICS WERE PROVIDED. OUTSIDE
OF WORK HOURS AND ON THE
WEEKENDS TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
HAD ACCESS AS NOT EVERYONE HAS
THE LUXURY. OF TAKING TIME OFF
DURING THE NORMAL WORKING DAY-
WE ALSO. WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TRANSLATION SERVICES- AND WERE
ABLE TO HELP. ARM CLIENTS FILL
OUT FORMS AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
IN THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE- AND WE
ALSO HELP EASE THEIR HESITANCY-
FOR UNDOCUMENTED. AND ARE
UNINSURED COMMUNITY MEMBERS. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO CREATED
AN ACT TASK FORCE- WERE WE MET
WEEKLY- WITH OTHER NONPROFITS IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHAT THE FOCUS ON
REACHING OUR FARMWORKERS
COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE ACESS TO
VACCINES. AND TESTING AS WELL AS
EDUCATION FOR THIS COMMUNITY.
OUR FIRST EVER A TESTING SITE WE
HAD AN OVERWHELMING DEMAND OR WE
HAVE SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE SHOW UP
SO GROCERY A PARKING LOT. AND SO
WE CAN REALIZE THAT THE NEED WAS
CRITICAL AND SO- WE HAVE
VACCINATED OVER SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE AND PROVIDED TESTING FOR
OVER FOUR THOUSAND. WE ALSO
NOTICED THAT THERE WAS- STARTED
TO BE A CRITICAL NEED AND FOOD
INSECURITY SO WE ESTABLISHED A
FOOD DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM WHERE
WE SET UP AWEEKLY FOOD DRIVE.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND FOOD BOXES.
WE ALSO ESTABLISHED A COVERT
OUTREACH TEAM- THAT PROVIDED
OVER OUTREACH EDUCATION. AND WE
HAVE OUR UCLA GETUP THE VACCINE
TEAM THAT HAS CANVASSED OVER TWO
THOUSAND HOURS KNOCKING ON DOORS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES OR ARE MOST
IMPACTED ZIP CODES AS WELL AS
OUR SAVIOR HEALTH GET OUT THE
VACCINE. FIFTY EIGHT THAT HAS
CALLED OVER NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE
I'M TRYING TO- ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS PERTAINING TO A
VACCINE SAFETY- OR ALSO
INFORMING THEM OF OUR NEXT
TEXTING CLINIC LOCATIONS. WE
ALSO A MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION
DEPARTMENT THAT WAS ABLE TO
PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION ACCESS-
TO THOSE THAT DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS
TO ATTEND A MEDICAL APPOINTMENT
OR ATTEND A VACCINE CLINIC. IN
CONJUNCTION THE CITY OF STOCKTON
WE ALSO OPERATED EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND
WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO HELP-
RENTERS WITH- UTILITY AND RENT
ASSISTANCE AS WELL AS PROVIDED
OBJECTION PREVENTION EDUCATION.
WE WERE ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING TO OVER FIVE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS- IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE WERE ALSO ABLE TO DISTRIBUTE
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSISTANCE. TO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY WHO WAS LEFT OUT OF
OUR FIRST- STIMULUS PROVIDED BY
THE GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO HELP
THEM AND PROVIDE SOME RELIEF.
I'M ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE FACED- AND THAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED IS THE LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY ON SOME OF OUR STATE
CONTRACTS. FOR EXAMPLE- WHAT THE
COVERT SHUTDOWN OCCURRED IN
MARCH WE SUBMITTED SOME ODD
BUDGET MODIFICATIONS AND BUDGET
QUESTIONS- TO THE STATE
REGARDING OUR PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. WE DIDN'T RECEIVE AN
ANSWER TO THOSE- AND TELL
OCTOBER WHICH KIND OF CREATED
SOME UNCERTAINTY- MENTAL ALLOWED
US TO HAVE TO COVER SOME UP
FRONT COSTS AS WE DECIDED TO
KEEP OUR PRESCHOOL DOORS OPEN.
TO PROVIDE- DAY CARE SERVICES TO
OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY- WE WERE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH THAT OUR OPERATING
BUDGET- ALLOWED US TO HAVE A
RAINY DAY FUND THAT WE DECIDED
THAT THE PANDEMIC- CALLED FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THOSE FUNDS-
INTEL WE RECEIVED THE QUESTIONS
TO OUR BUDGET- CONCERNS.
REGARDING REIMBURSEMENTS- RATES
. SO WE ARE VERY THANKFUL FOR
THE WORK THAT WE GET TO DO EVERY
DAY IN OUR COMMUNITY- AND ALSO
ALL THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
LOCAL NONPROFITS- THE PANDEMIC
HAS EXEMPLIFIED THAT WE ARE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS. AND THAT- WE
ARE ABLE TO TAKE THE LEAD ON
CRESTWOOD EFFORTS AND ACTUALLY
HELP THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. SO AS WE GO BACK TO.
NORMAL WHATEVER THAT CASE MAY BE
WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH OUR NON PROFITS AS WE HAVE
SHOWN THE ABILITY TO REACH. OUR
COMMUNITIES AND HELP THOSE MOST
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I'M
NEXT WE'LL HEAR. NEWS VOLUNTEER
CENTER. CHAIRWOMAN RIVAS
CHAIRWOMAN LIMÓN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TO SHARE SOME OF THE LESSONS WE
LEARNED FROM OUR RESPONSES TO
THE PANDEMIC AND THE CZ U. FIRES
WHICH HAPPENED AT THE SAME TIME
OUR CENTER IS THE HOME TO ABOUT
A DOZEN IMPACT PROGRAMS SO WE DO
DIRECT SERVICES AND WE ALSO WORK
TO CONNECT THREE HUNDRED LOCAL
NONPROFIT PARTNERS TO VOLUNTEERS
pTHESE OTHER SMALL GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR COMMUNITY SO I'D
LIKE TO. TALK WITH BOTH HATS ON-
YOU KNOW NOTHING SYMBOLIZES HOW
GREAT WE ARE AT- MOVING QUICKLY
TO OVERCOME BARRIERS TO SERVICE
AS THESE MASKS- EARLY SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES AND LACK OF PPE-
BECAUSE WE OFTEN ARE UNDER
RESOURCE WE DO WE CROWDSOURCE
THIS WE DELIVERED OUR FIRST
THOUSAND MASS TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND NEW SHELTER PARTNERS
WITHIN A WEEK WE STOPPED
COUNTING AT TWENTY THOUSAND I
THINK- YOU KNOW WE TRANSITION
OUR COUNSELING SO CENTERS TO
TELEHEALTH. ARE NEED PROGRAMS
WHERE PEOPLE CAME TO US IN IN A
MEAL TO DRIVE THROUGH MEETING
ARE TRANSUNION TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS TO FOOD DELIVERY
PROGRAMS AS YOU'RE HEARING A LOT
THIS OUT ADAPTABILITY TO MEET
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE IT'S NOT
UNIQUE TO US IT'S A CORE
COMPETENCY OF THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR AND I REALLY THINK THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR STEPPING
IN AND HELPING WITH THIS ISSUE
ABOUT GETTING SOME FLEXIBILITY
IN CONTRACTING IT IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO OUR SUCCESS. NOW
IT'S OUR PEOPLE WHO DELIVER
THESE RESULTS AT A TIME WHEN WE
WERE REINVENTING EVERYTHING
ABOUT OURSELVES TO MEET CRITICAL
NEEDS WE ALSO WERE LAYING OFF 5%
OF OUR STAFF WE ENACTED A ONE
YEAR WAGE FREEZE AND OUR STAFF
ON TOP OF THAT TOOK AN
ADDITIONAL 10% FOR LOW TO SAVE.
THE JOBS OF THREE MORE CO
WORKERS. WITHOUT SUSTAINED
INVESTMENT IN THE TO PAY FOR WAY
FAR. WORKERS BY FUNDERS AT EVERY
. OUTSIDE OF DISASTERS THERE'S
NO WAY WE CAN THRIVE AND BE
READY TO RESPOND. DURING THE
NEXT DISASTER THAT WE ALL THAT
WAS COMING. I DO NOT KNOW A
SINGLE SMALL AND MIDSIZE
NONPROFIT IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
ARE ON THE CENTRAL COAST THAT IS
NOT STRUGGLING LIKE WE ARE TO
FILL THE VACANCIES AND PAY A
FAIR WAGE IN THESE HGH COST
COUNTIES. LOCAL NONPROFITS AS I
AGREE AS THE VOTE MANY OF SAID
HOW DEEP COMMUNITY ROOTS AND
WE'RE TRUSTED PEOPLE- PARTICULAR
BY FOLKS WHO ARE HIGHER RISK FOR
HARD TO REACH IN DISASTER.
ACCESS TO THESE DEEP ROOT
NETWORKS ARE WIN WIN FOR OUR
STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS. AS
WELL AS FOR OUR FOLKS AND ONE
EXAMPLE OF THIS WE HAD A PRE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
WHEN CODE HIT. IN THE TWO WEEKS
CALIFORNIA WAS CLOSING DOWN WE
WERE ABLE TO REACH OUT TO OUR-
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERS SO THAT
WHEN SCHOOLS CLOSED IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR TWO LARGEST-
SPANISH SPEAKING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS UP POP WROTE. AND LIVE
VOTE. WHEN EVERY PARENT WHO IS
SPANISH SPEAKING SHOWED UP TO
GET THEIR POCKETS AND TECHNOLOGY
THEY WERE ALSO MET WITH SOMEONE
TO BE GIVEN. COVERED GUIDES IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH KEEP YOUR
FAMILYBECAUSE OF ITS STATE WE
WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
PROVIDER SO IS EVERYBODY WAS
DELIVERING FOOD AND MEALS ON
WHEELS IS TRUSTED PARTNERS.
DELIVERED INFORMATION THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO BROKER AND AS WE'RE
WORKING WITH OUR COUNTY THE SET
UP MASS VACCINES SITES. WE SAW
OUR NONPROFIT PARTNERS- NOT
ALMOST SIGNING PEOPLE UP BUT-
OFFERING POP UPS. BRINGING
PEOPLE TO THE WE HAD A QUICK
LISTED IF THEY WERE AT. EXTRA
SHOTS AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
WOULD COLOR NONPROFITS AND THEY
WOULD BRING. BRING FOLKS- MOST
SMALL NONPROFITS WOULD LOVE TO
DO MORE OF THIS AND THEY WOULD
BE A POWERFUL FORCE FOR EQUITY.
BUT EVEN WHEN THEIR STATE
FUNDING AVAILABLE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPITAL ON HAND. TO START OF
THESE NEW SERVICES NOW WE'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE A CREDIT
LINE. BUT THIS YEAR THE FIRST
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS MY
NONPROFIT. REYES IS NOT GOING TO
MY STAFF OR TO INCREASING OUR
SERVICES IT'S GOING TO PAY DEBT
ON MY CREDIT LINE WHILE WE WAIT
FOR REIMBURSEMENT. ON STATE AND
FEDERAL CONTRACTS AND THAT IS AN
UNNECESSARY BUSINESS BARRIER TO
EFFECTIVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT WE
HOPE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
REMEDY. NOW IN ADDITION TO THE
STOP LABOR MARKET ISSUES
NONPROFITS ARE FACING WITH MY
VOLUNTEER CENTER HAD ON  WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE VOLUNTEER
LABOR CHALLENGE. AS IN PERSON
SERVICES A REOPENING MOST LOCAL
NONPROFITS ARE FINDING THAT
TWENTY FIVE TO FORTY PERCENT.
OTHER VOLUNTEERS ARE NOT
RETURNING AND THE LARGEST GROUP
OF LOS VOLUNTEERS ARE IN OUR
ELDERS. THE GREAT NEWS IS THAT
THERE'S A HEIGHTENED INTEREST IN
VOLUNTEERING. PARTICULARLY AMONG
MILLENNIALS. BUT WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE CRISIS AND LOCAL
NONPROFITS THEY LACKED THE
TECHNOLOGY. THE TRAINING AND THE
TOOLS TO ENGAGE THIS YOUNGER
VOLUNTEER WORK FORCE WHO HAVE
PRETTY HIGH EXPECTATIONS. IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE THAT'S GOING TO BE
SOLVED BY A CALL TO SERVICE OR
AN ONLINE STATEMENT REGISTRY
BECAUSE THE POBLEM ISN'T THAT
WE NEED MORE PEOPLE TO WANT TO
VOLUNTEER. EVERY SMALL NONPROFIT
WE WORK WITH IS STRUGGLING RIGHT
NOW WITH STAFF VACANCIES.
INCREASED DEMAND FOR SERVICE OLD
COMPUTERS. STILL STAGNANT DONOR
DATA DATABASES AN AGING
TECHNOLOGY. SO THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO ON BOARD ANY QUICK
PLEASE NAME VOLUNTEERS THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE THEM. AND THESE
REASONABLE AND MODEST
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS A NEW
COMPUTER. AS A SIMPLE OUT THE
COST TO BACKGROUND CHECK AND
ENSURE VOLUNTEERS. BILL LOOK
LIKE OVERHEAD IN BUDGETS AND SO
THEY'RE DIFFICULT TO SELL TO THE
DONOR AND PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITY. BUT SMART. SMALL
INVESTMENTS. TO THE SCRIPT.
THROUGHOUT OUR VOLUNTEER NOT ALL
OUR VOLUNTEER CONSUMING
NONPROFIT NETWORK WOULD PAY HUGE
DIVIDENDS INCREASE DONATIONS OF
TIME TALENT AND FUNDING FOR
FRONTLINE LOCAL WORKERS AND
IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE READY WE
WOULD BE. TO MEET FUTURE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE SURE TO COME
BECAUSE THIS INTEREST IN THIS
NEW INTEREST IN VOLUNTEERING IF
WE DON'T CAPTURE THAT NOW. WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO GET IT BACK
A YEAR FROM NOW OR TWO YEARS
FROM NOW WHEN THE NEXT DISASTER
IS ALREADY HERE. SO I THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING OUR PERSPECTIVES
I THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE
VALUE OF VOLUNTEERS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
CREATE THE THRIVING SUSTAINABLE
COMPLETED IS. THAT WE ALL
DESERVE. THANK YOU KAREN- OUR
FINAL SPEAKER ON THIS FIRST
PANEL IS JANET MARY NOT SHOW UP
CEO OF MEN SERVING THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. WELCOME JANET
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY CHAIR RIVAS
SENATE SHERRY REHMAN AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY I'M SO HONORED TO
SERVE AS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
LAND WHICH HAS SERVED THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FOR MORE THAN
FIFTY YEARS COVIDIEN ARE VALLEY
HARD PARTICULARLY THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HOME TO
PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE THE MOST
EVEN WHEN THERE'S NOT A CRISIS
LIKE COBIT THOSE RUN HOUSE OR
LIVE FAR BELOW THE POVERTY LINE.
AT ONE POINT DURING THE PEAK OF
THE FIRST WAVE PROCLAIM AWARE
MEANT IS LOCATED BECAME THE
EPICENTER OF INFECTIONS IN LA
COUNTY WITH THE HIGHEST CASE
RIGHT PER HUNDRED THOUSAND MANY
OF THE PEOPLE WE SERVE WHILE
THEY MAY BE SHELTERED WOULD MEET
THE FEDERAL DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS THAT IS THEY LIVE
IN CONDITIONS UNFIT FOR HUMAN
HABITATION THEY LIVE IN GARAGES
LEAN TO'S CRAWL SPACES THERE
DOUBLED AND TRIPLED UP. ON THE
THEY DON'T GET COUNTED DURING
THE HOMELESS COUNTS SO MOST
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW THEY'RE
THERE THE VALLEY DOESN'T HAVE A
SKID ROW WE'RE SEEING MORE IN
CABINETS. BUT POVERTY IS LARGELY
HIDDEN. OUR NURSE. PROGRAMS
WHICH INCLUDE A FOOD PANTRY AND
FOOD BANKS I INCREASES IN DEMAND
AS HIGH AS FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT.
COMPARED TO NON COATED YEARS.
THE NEED REMAINS HIGH AS GROCERY
PRICES SKYROCKET AND ANY
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE ECONOMY HAVE
NOT TRICKLED DOWN TO THEM. MODOC
SICKLY THIS CRISIS IS ALSO
AFFORDED MANDING CREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY IN A MORE ROBUST WAY
FOR EXAMPLE CARES ACT FUNDING
WAS DEPLOYED TO ENHANCE OUR FOOD
DISTRIBUTIONS AND PROVIDE ON THE
GROUND INFORMATION AND RESOURCES
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WITH BECAUSE IT'S PHYSICAL. AND
MENTAL HEALTH EFFECTS AND MORE
DOLLARS CAME AFTER THAT FROM
PRIVATE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
SOURCES. BECAUSE OF THE FLOOD OF
MONEY GOVERNMENT ENTITIES LIKE
L. A. COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
SUBCONTRACTED WITH
INTERMEDIARIES TO DISTRIBUTE THE
GRASS SOME HAD NEVER MANAGE
PUBLIC FUNDS LEAVING THEM. WITH
A BIG LEARNING CURVE AND A VERY
SHORT WINDOW TO GET THE DOLLARS
OUT AND AGENCIES LIKE OURS FOUND
THEMSELVES ACCEPTING BONTA ON
PUBLIC FUNDING FOR THE FIRST
TIME SCRAMBLING TO SET UP.
SYSTEMS TO MANAGE THE DOLLARS
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY.
DESPITE THESE CAPACITY CHANGES
BECAUSE OF THESE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS WE WERE ABLE TO
EXPAND OUR REACH EMPLOY MORE
PEOPLE SERVE EVEN MORE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND BREATHED A LITTLE
EASIER. SINCE THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE SERVED OUR
COMMUNITY THROUGH ONE POINT SIX
MILLION SERVICE ENCOUNTERS WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED OVER SIX MILLION
POUNDS OF FOOD SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EAT CATS AND THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH VACCINE
PROVIDERS WE HAVE SO FAR THIS
ELIMINATED OVER FORTY SIX
HUNDRED DOSES. THROUGH THREE
QUARTERS OF A MILLION ENCOUNTERS
WE PUT THE FOOD ON THE TABLE A
FAMILIES MOST OF WHOM USED A
FOOD PANTRY FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AND MIGHT OTHERWISE HAVE GONE
WITHOUT. SO WHAT KEEPS ME UP AT
NIGHT IS WONDERING WHAT'S NEXT
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT'S ALL OVER
OUR BOARD AND I REGULARLY TALK
ABOUT THE IMPENDING FUNDING
CLIFF HOW DO WE ENSURE THE
SERVICES PEOPLE NEED TO RECOVER.
ARE THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING GOES AWAY WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THERE'S ANOTHER EMERGENCY A
WILD FIRE AND EARTHQUAKE. HOW DO
WE DEPLOY SERVICES IF OUR OWN
FACILITY IS DAMAGED. AS A RESULT
OF THESE QUESTIONS ARE CURRENT
STRATEGIC PLAN IS GROUNDED IN
BUILDING THE RESILIENCE OF OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OUR COMMUNITY
SO THAT WE ARE READY FOR THE
NEXT CRISIS. IN ORDER TO DO THAT
ON GOING INVESTMENTS IN THE
SECTOR ARE REQUIRED. TO CONTINUE
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY WE NEED TO
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL OF RESILIENCE.
PEOPLE NEED ACCESS TO GOOD WELL
PAYING JOBS INCLUDING OUR OWN
STAFF IT'S HARD TO KEEP UP WITH
THE INCREASING AND JUSTIFY
DEMAND FOR HIGHER WAGES WHEN THE
FUNDS AWARDED TO NONPROFITS.
HAVE LARGELY REMAINED STAGNANT.
I KNOW THE NEXT PANEL WILL TALK
ABOUT RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
NEXT EMERGENCY BUT I WANT TO
URGE EVERYONE TO REMEMBER THAT
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE ONES WE
SERVE. STRUGGLE DAILY POVERTY IS
AN EMERGENCY HOMELESSNESS IS AN
EMERGENCY FOR THEM THE NEXT
EMERGENCY IS TOMORROW AND THE
NEXT ONE THE DAY AFTER THAT.
LIFE IN POVERTY IS A SERIES OF
MICRO TRAUMAS OF SHAME GUILT
EMBARRASSMENT FEAR THAT
ACCUMULATE KEEPING PEOPLE IN
SURVIVAL MODE. WE CAN NO LONGER
LONGER LOOKING HOMELESSNESS AS A
MONOLITH THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SHELTERED BUT NOT HOUSED WHO
MAY NEED NOTHING MORE THAN
ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY IN A FAIR
WAY TO MAKE THAT NEXT STEP WE
MUST PREVENT. THOSE AT RISK FROM
FALLING INTO DEEPER CRISIS AND
THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY IN DEEP
CRISIS NEED TO BE LIFTED OUT
EVEN BEFORE THE NEXT EMERGENCY.
THE EFFECTS OF THIS PANDEMIC
WILL NOT END THE DAY THE CDC
DECLARES IS NOW ENDEMIC THE
ECONOMIC AND PERSONAL INJURIES
WILL CARRY ON FOR SOMETIME TO
COME. WE CAN'T FORGET THESE
DAILY STRUGGLES AS WE BEGIN TO
GO ABOUT OUR BUSINESS AS YOU
USUAL AND WHICH- FORGET TO
STRENGTHEN. THE SAFETY NET THAT
IS THE NON PROFITS THAT ARE HERE
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HEARING MY AND MY
COLLEAGUES REMARKS TODAY. THANK
YOU JANET THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING US THAT SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE IN ALREADY IN A
STATE IN A IN A OF EMERGENCY AND
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE BECAUSE OF POVERTY. ARE AND
SO THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU TO
ALL THE PANELISTS- FOR SHARING
YOUR EXPERIENCES AND YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS I WILL NOW OPEN
IT UP TO QUESTIONS FROM THE-
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANTED TO THAT WAS A
MIGHT DROP FROM JANET I THINK
SHE HIT ALL THE POINTS- BUT I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD ASK
OURSELVES WHAT KEEPS UP US UP AT
NIGHT AND IF. YOU DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM SLEEPING AT NIGHT THEN I
THINK YOU NEED TO MAKE SOME
REASSESSMENTS- IN YOUR IN YOUR
OWN COMMUNITY BECAUSE I KNOW AND
I HAVE HEARD WITH JANET SAID
WILL KEEP HER UP AT NIGHT. THE
SAME THING KEEPS ME UP AT NIGHT
I WOULD A CHILD DOESN'T COME
HOME- WE'RE IN- YOU KNOW WE GET
A CALL FROM JUSTICE FOR MURDERED
CHILDREN OR PARENTS OF MURDERED
CHILDREN IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION TO GO AND STAND
WITH PARENTS. WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR THEIR CHILDREN I'M TO GUN
VIOLENCE- IN IN LOS ANGELES AND
SO THOSE AND IT IS A JANET HOW
ARE WILLING ARTICULATED THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT SHOULD KEEP
US UP AT NIGHT- AND I THINK THAT
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY WANTS TO
HEAR. THE VOICES OF ALL THE
PANELISTS AND I WANT TO
APPRECIATE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
THEM FOR SPEAKING I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE PART THAT WE'RE GET TODAY
WITH REAL SOLUTIONS. ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS BECAUSE YOU SHOULD
NOT HAVING YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO MAX OUT YOUR CREDIT CARD- AND
WAITING FOR STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDS TO COME- BECAUSE. IT YOU
KNOW YOU NEVER. I CAN FORESEE N.
DOES. OR A EMERGENCY- THAT COMES
UP AS A NONPROFIT. IN THE YOU
DON'T HAVE MONEY IN ORDER TO
MAKE ENDS MEET IT IS THE SAME
THING THAT PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
WITH. EVEN IN OUR OWN HOUSEHOLD
ACCOUNTS RIGHT ROBIN PAUL TO PAY
PETER. AND I THINK THAT THAT WE
SHOULD PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR
MOUTH IS WE SHOULD LOOK AT. HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THESE THAT.
CHECKS ARE ARE A GENERATED IN A
VERY RESPONSIBLE- IN A- IN A
THOUGHTFUL TIME SO THESE
NONPROFITS GET. CAN GET THE
MONEY THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
EXPANDED AND SUPPORTED- IN WAYS
OF SUPPORTING THE COMMUNITY
UNDERGIRDED COMMUNITY. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT ROBUST
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AT THAT PARTICULAR
TIME. AND I THINK AS I CLOSE
WHAT KEEPS YOU UP AT NIGHT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT. OF
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
CHAIR RIVAS I DO HAVE TO PUT
PRETTY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS- FOR
THE NON PROFITS ONE- EARLIER A
FEW WEEKS AGO WE WERE CRAFTING A
BILL TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
NONPROFITS QUALIFIED LIKE
BUSINESSES- FOR ALL OF THE GRANT
SIX CENTER THERE ARE OUT THERE
BY THE STATE AND WE GOT PUSHED
BACK SAYING THAT'S ALREADY THE
CASE THAT WE DON'T NEED THIS
LEGISLATION. SO I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ASK THE NON PROFITS IF
YOU HAVE EXPERIENCES WHERE
YOU'RE APPLYING FOR GRANTS AND
YOU'RE BEING TOLD- IF YOU'RE A
BUSINESS YOU CAN GET IT BUT AS A
NON PROFIT YOU CAN'T- IF YOU
COULD CONTACT MY OFFICE AND LET
ME KNOW BECAUSE- THAT SAYS A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INTRODUCE IF WE NEED IT BUT AT
THIS POINT TIME. OF STAFF-
COMMITTEE STAFFERS INDICATED
THAT THAT WE DON'T THIS THE
SECOND THING IS MORE
PHILOSOPHICAL BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
AT THE UNITED STATES WE HAVE
ALWAYS HONORED THE FOR THE SMALL
FARMER WE'VE. ALWAYS HONORED TO
SMALL BUSINESS PERSON. AND THE
ENTERED. ARE PRETTY EASY TO WIN
SUPPORT FOR POLITICALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO FUNDING EXCITER. WE
JUST SOMEHOW HAVE NOT FOUND A
WAY TO ELEVATE NON PROFITS TO
THE SAME STATUS EVERYBODY LIKES
HIM. BUT WE DON'T THINK ABOUT%
HIM WHEN IT'S LIKE OH WE HAVE
THIS ECONOMIC PROBLEM WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO FOR SMALL
BUSINESS. WE HONESTLY WE'RE
GOING TO FOR SMALL BUSINESS AND
NONPROFITS AT THE SAME TIME. AND
IF EVERYBODY THE BLUE OF THE-
TALENTED- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND I
SERVE RESIDENTS SENATOR- CAN ALL
AND SENATORS CAN ALL HELP ME
THINK ABOUT HOW WE DO THAT. I'D
REALLY BE AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT RESPONSE THANK YOU. SENATOR
BAKER. I THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO
THOSE IS ECHO WE HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AND- JUST TO THINK
ALL THE SPEAKERS AND FOR THE
WORK THAT THAT DAY AND THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS AND COUNTLESS
OTHER NONPROFITS- HAVE DONE
DURING THE PANDEMIC THANKS FOR
THAT COMPELLING ATTEST TO MY
LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSING. SOME
OF THE SOLUTIONS GOING FORWARD.
K. CENTER LAMONT. THANK YOU AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THAT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT I HEARD A FEW
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN TEAMS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS. THE A DO
THINK NEED ADDRESSING- AND I
WANT TO POINT THOSE THINGS OUT-
WEEK WE HEARD ISSUES. RELATED TO
THE ZERO FIVE H. PRESCHOOLS
CHILD CARE WHICH CONTINUE TO BE-
AN ISSUE I KNOW THAT. WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO THEM THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE THE LAST IN LINE TO HEAR
WHAT THE GUIDELINES ARE HAD TO
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS AND SO-
THAT THAT FEELS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN ECHOED REALLY ACROSS
THE STATE. THAT WE HEARD ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE AND FLEXIBILITY
IN CONTRACTING OVER AND OVER AND
OVER DURING AN EMERGENCY- WE
HAVE UNDERSTOOD THAT IN ORDER
FOR. OUR NON PROFITS TO ADAPT BE
NEED SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
CONTRACTING WE HAVE HAD TO ADAPT
OUR OWN JOBS SO I THINK IT'S THE
SHOULD EXPECT THAT THERE'S- A
MORE WILL HELP. THE SAME THING
IN OUR A STEEP ESPECIALLY IF
THEIR CONTRACT WITH THE STATE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE MUST
RECOGNIZE I KNOW THAT AND A
MEMBER U. S. X. REF A LETTER-
THAT WENT OUT EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC THAT SEVERAL OF US YOU
KNOW SIGNED ON TO- AND WE'RE
PART OF THAT. THAT ASKED THE
STATE TO DO THAT AND THE STATE
DID- BUT CERTAINLY IF THERE ARE
ELEMENTS WHERE WE COULD DO A
BETTER JOB OF CONTRACT OF THE OF
PROVIDING THAT FLEXIBILITY IN
CONTRACTING. I WOULD BE VERY
OPEN TO HEARING ABOUT. THAT- YOU
KNOW. IF WE THE WAITING FOR-
ANGLE INTO. IS IT IS IT EVEN TO
REALLY HEARTBREAKING AND- YOU
KNOW I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON. REFER TO THAT BUT THAT
IS A HUGE PROBLEM ASKING OUR
NONPROFITS TO GO INTO DEBT
BECAUSE THE STATE- IS LAGGING ON
A REIMBURSEMENT I HOPE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN LOOK INTO
AS THE LEGISLATURE- WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO HELP OUR- NONPROFIT
SURVIVE. AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
WAIT PERIODS ARE WHY THERE ARE
SUCH LONG WAIT PERIODS- TO GET
THOSE REIMBURSEMENT- FROM THE
CONTRACTS I THINK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND.
I BOTH WAS WORRIED BUT ALSO
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE COMMENTS
RELATED TO THE VOLUNTEER LABOR
CHALLENGES- THE FACT THAT WE'RE
LOSING TWENTY FIVE TO PART 40%
OF OUR VOLUNTEERS- WHO TEND TO
BE MOSTLY ELDERS- WHEN WE KNOW
THAT ALSO THE PANDEMIC HAS
FORCED TO YOU KNOW FOR HEALTH
REASONS AND SAFETY REASONS- FOR
US UP YOU KNOW FOR ALL OF US TO
BE MORE CAREFUL. BUT CERTAINLY
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS- THAT
WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF THAT WERE
LOSING VOLUNTEERS BUT I WAS
OPTIMISTIC WHEN I HEARD THAT MY
LABIALS. ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
LIKE SIGN ME UP I WANT TO
VOLUNTEER AND SO I HOPE AND THAT
WE COULD ALSO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THAT ABOUT WHAT ARE THE WAYS
THAT WE- COULD SUPPORT THAT WE
COULD. YOU KNOW SIT WHETHER IT'S
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALLY OR IF
THERE ARE LEGISLATIVE TOOLS THAT
MAKE IT EASIER FOR MILLENNIALS
TO VOLUNTEER THAT SOMETHING
THAT. I WOULD ALSO LOVE TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE THEMES- WHAT WAS MENTIONED
TO DATE IS NOT- THEY'RE NOT
ISOLATED THINGS LIKE WE AYE I
KNOW WE'VE HEARD THIS I'VE I'VE
HEARD THIS- AND THESE THEMES
REALLY COME UP AS WELL. AS YOU
YOU TALK TO NONPROFITS ACROSS
THE STATE AND SO- I APPRECIATE
THERE ARE NONPROFITS STILL HANG
IN THERE KNOWING AND THAT THERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES-AND HOPE
THAT THIS ALLOWS US TO FURTHER
LOOK INTO SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
TO SEE HOW THE STATE COULD BE A
BETTER PARTNER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR LEE MY- I. WANT TO
ADD ON TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ALREADY. BROUGHT UP AS AS
ISSUES AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HEARD. OF BUT ONE THING
I THOUGHT ABOUT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. THE LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY ON STATE CONTRACTS
THAT. WE ALSO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOMETIMES THESE
CONTRACTS. DO NOT COVER THE FULL
COSTS. OF THE- SERVICES THAT ARE
DELIVERED NONPROFITS HAVE TO
HAVE FUND RAISERS THEIR-
FUNDRAISING GALAS IN APPEALS AT
THE END OF THE YEAR. TO COVER
THE GAP. I'M IN IT IT FEELS THAT
WE'RE NOT VALUING. THEIR
SERVICES THE SERVICES THAT THEY
ARE PROVIDING TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS. ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT PAYING THEM
ENOUGH TO DO IT. AND SO I HOPE
THAT. WE THINK ABOUT THAT TOO IS
LIKE WHAT IS THE COST TO DELIVER
THESE CRITICAL SERVICES- IN
TIMES OF NEED ESPECIALLY. OF A-
THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT JANET WAS
SAYING ABOUT THE FUNDING CLIFF
AFTER FOR COVERT NINETEEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE CDC. DECLARES
THIS PANDEMIC OVER. AND BUT
THERE'S STILL A HUGE NEED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND HOW DO WE
CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT TO GET PEOPLE BACK ON
THEIR FEET BACK INTO JOBS.
CHILDREN INTO PRESCHOOLS- AT
CETERA AND SO I HOPE THAT WE AS
A LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO PRESS.
FOR THOSE MUCH NEEDED SERVICES.
AND AS FAR AS VOLUNTEERS WHEN
KAREN WAS TALKING. ABOUT
VOLUNTEERS. I THOUGHT OF MY OWN
EXPERIENCE DURING THE PANDEMIC
MY OFFICE GOT SO MANY CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS THAT. WANTED TO
VOLUNTEER THEY WANTED TO HELP.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO OR WHERE
TO GO- BUT WE CONSTANTLY GOT
CALLS FROM YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF
CONSTITUENTS THAT WERE READY. TO
GO BUT- WHEN KAREN TALKED ABOUT
THE COSTS TO ON BOARD VOLUNTEERS
RIGHT BACKGROUND CHECKS.
EVERYTHING THAT'S CONSIDERED
OVERHEAD AND YOU KNOW AS A
FORMER NON PROFIT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. THAT'S LIKE
UNFORTUNATELY OF BAD WERE YOU
DON'T WNT ALL YOUR MONEY- TO
SHOW UP AS OVERHEAD RIGHT WE
WANT IT DIRECTLY TO PROGRAM
SERVICES BECAUSE OUR FUNDERS
DEMAND THAT RATE THEY WANT. I
HAD THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
YOUR BUDGET TO BE ALLOCATED TO
PROGRAM SERVICES BUT THIS IS A
PROGRAM SERVICE SO HOW DO WE
WORK. WITH THE FUNDING COMMUNITY
INCLUDING THE STATE HOW DO WE-
WORK TO MAKE SURE. THAT YOU KNOW
WE ARE ABLE TO ON BOARD ALL OF
THESE VOLUNTEERS TRAIN THEM AND
HELP US WITH THE MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES BETTER. AND THAT WE
NEED DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY- I HAD ONE QUESTION
FOR KAREN DELANEY OF VOLUNTEERS
. THE SANTA CRUZ VOLUNTEER
CENTER- I WOULD ASK WHAT CAN WE
DO TO HELP VOLUNTEERS BE
PREPARED. FOR TIMES OF CRISIS.
AND WHAT DO YOU FIND AS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF USING PEOPLE'S
GROWING DESIRE TO VOLUNTEER
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUEST FOR THAT
QUESTION- YOU KNOW. THERE IS A
GREAT WHEN THERE'S A COMMUNITY
THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE OURS A STRONG
VOLUNTEER CONNECTING
ORGANIZATION- HANDS AND LA-
HANDS ON BAY AREA THE VOLUNTEER
CENTER OF SACRAMENTO THE
VOLUNTEER CENTER HERE SOMETIMES
IT'S THE UNITED WAY. AND SO
THERE'S A GREAT UNEVENNESS FOR
COMMUNITIES LIKE OURS THAT ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HARM AND OR AN
ORGANIZATION THAT CAN PAY FOR
THE WEBSITE AND THE TECHNOLOGY
AND HELP CONNECT PEOPLE THAT'S A
LEG UP SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE
CAN DO. IS TO TRY AND PUT SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I'M USING
THAT TERM THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF-
MAKING IT EASIER TO CONNECT
LOCALLY. AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF HELPING NONPROFITS SO HELPING
IT A LITTLE BIT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE GOES A LONG WAY
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
CONNECT TO WHERE THE HELP IS
NEEDED. AND THAT'S A LOCAL OR
REGIONAL EFFORT- THE OTHER THING
THOUGH IS. WHEN EVERY WEEK MY-
WHEN RECRUITING YOUNGER. THIS
ONBOARDING COSTS I THINK THAT-
AS YOU POINTED OUT. IT HAS TO BE
BOTH SIDES OF THE EQUATION WE
HAVE TO GET BETTER TECHNOLOGY
I'M ONE OF THE MEMBERS MENTIONED
BROADBAND WE HAVE TO GET BETTER
TECHNOLOGY AND ACCESS TO. FREE
QUICK BACKGROUND CHECKS
SOMETHING LIKE TEXAS HAS A
VOLUNTEER FAST PASS THAT THAT
THAT THE THAT THEY PAY FOR WHERE
ONCE I'M A VOLUNTEER GETS THEIR
FREE RECORDS THEY CAN TAKE THAT.
FROM AND BE ONBOARDED QUICKER SO
THERE ARE THERE ARE REAL SIMPLE
SOLUTIONS. THAT WILL HELP MAKE
THIS PROCESS EASIER RIGHT NOW
ALL OF THE COSTS ARE ON THE
LOCAL NONPROFITS WE JUST DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO RESPOND. I
AGREE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IDEAS AND YOUR ANSWERS O NEXT.
WE'RE READY TO MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT PANEL- OUR FINAL PANEL OF
WEEK THAT IS IDENTIFYING FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUPPORT
NONPROFITS DURING EMERGENCIES.
WE HAVE FOUR PANELISTS THAT WILL
EACH SPEAK TO US FOR FIVE
MINUTES WE'LL START WITH. JOHN
MASSA OKEH CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFITS ARE
CAL NONPROFITS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER REQUEST AND
ASKED SENATOR MONIQUE LIMON YOU
KNOW IT IS REALLY AMAZING NUMBER
ALL HERE TODAY WITH THESE TWO
COMMITTEE SEVEN BEEN FORMED IN
LEADING AND IT'S SO HEARTENING
TO US NONPROFITS TO SEE. HOW
MANY MEMBERS THERE ARE WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN COMING TOGETHER
AND MAKING THE BEST USE POSSIBLE
OF CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFITS. JUST
A COUPLE WORDS FIRST ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS TO RESTATE CAL
NONPROFITS FOR SHORT WE ARE A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITH
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
NONPROFITS THAT ARE MEMBERS AND
WE ACT AS KIND OF A CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE FOR NONPROFITS. BUT
MOSTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
TO PROTECT ENHANCE NONPROFITS
ABILITY TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ALSO TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
ECONOMY AND ALL OF YOU WHAT THE
SPEAKERS AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF
THE TO COMMITTEES. HAVE REALLY
SPOKEN TO UNDERSTANDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF BOTH OF THESE
ASPECTS. SORRY JUST RECENTLY WE-ARE OUTRAGE PARTNER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS AND
NONPROFITS BB FRANCIS WELLS
CALVIN USED. BY THE INCLUSION OF
NON PROFITS IN THESE PROGRAMS
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR LEGISLATORS. WHO
MADE SURE THAT WE WERE INCLUDED-
EVEN THOUGH THAT MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN IN THE EARLY CHECK OUT SO
AGAIN RICH ASKING YOUR COMMENT-
WELL MISTER BENNETT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. SPEAKING OUT
FROM OUR LEGISLATIVE ALLIES IN
THE LAST YEAR WE'VE HAD THIRTY
ONE TOWN HALLS AND WEBINARS SOME
OF THEM WITH MORE THAN A
THOUSAND NONPROFITS
PARTICIPATING. IN WHICH PEOPLE
CAN LEARN AND TALK MANY OF YOU
HAVE ALSO MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. AND BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF ALL WITH ALSO
PARTICIPATED. I AM THESE TOWN
HALLS AND WEBINARS AND AS YOU
KNOW WITH THE TO SELECT
COMMITTEES WE ALSO ARE HOLDING
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT STAY IN
WHICH- LEGISLATORS ARE INVITED
TO HONOR AND NONPROFIT IT'S A
YEAR AND THEY'RE DISTRICTS. LAST
YEAR HUNDRED FOURTEEN OUT OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY LEGISLATORS CHOSE
TO NAME NONPROFIT CITY YEAR
WHICH IS VERY EXCITING AND EVEN
MORE EXCITING IS THAT THIS YEAR
WE'RE GONNA BE BACK IN PERSON.
ON. THE CAPITOL LAWN ON JUNE
EIGHTH. SO NON. SUPPORTS AND I
THINK MANY THESE THINGS YOU JUST
HEARD THAT WE ARE HE WROTE FIRST
AND SECOND RESPONDENTS THAT WERE
PART OF IT. WE ARE REALLY A
CRUCIAL PART OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
FOR SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN
WE HIRE WE HIRE LOCALLY WE SPEND
LOCALLY AND WE KEEP ALL THE JOBS
LOCAL WE DON'T RELOCATE TO
ANOTHER STATE WE CAN'T. OUR
HIGHEST PAID JOBS ARE MORE OFTEN
HELD Y WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR THAN THE FOR PROFIT
SECTOR. AND IS MET HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BE BRINGING FORTY
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FROM OUT
OF STATE. INCLUDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM OUT OF
STATE FOUNDATIONS AS WELL AS
FROM INDIVIDUAL DONORS ALL
AROUND THE WORLD WE'RE SO
ADMIRING OF CALIFORNIA'S
INNOVATIVE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY.
AND THIS CAN'T MENTION WE
LEVERAGE THE ECONOMICAL THE
EQUIVALENT OF A VOLUNTEER IS IN
CALIFORNIA THE EQUIVALENT OF
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND. FULL TIME JOBS ARE ARE
THAT WORK IS DONE BY VOLUNTEERS
IN CALIFORNIA SO THESE ARE ALL
IMPORTANT WAYS THAT. SUPPORTING
NONPROFITS I END UP HAVING A
VERY HIGH MULTIPLIER EFFECT. SO
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC BUT AS OTHERS SPEAKERS
AND MENTION WE HAVE A LOT OF
NORMAL IF YOU WELL I'D MERGING
SEES ME FALL HAD EARTHQUAKES
WILDFIRES- MUDSLIDES IN DROUGHT
THESE ARE KIND OF OUR USUAL
EMERGENCIES- THAT. ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO COME UP SO
THESE ARE SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS
FOR WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THE WORK THAT WE DO.
FIRST IS JUST RECOGNIZING THE
POWER OF GOVERNMENT RELIEF. YOU
KNOW IN JUST THE FIRST PART. OF
THE CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF PROGRAM WHICH WE WERE A
PARTNER MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
NONPROFITS RECEIVED GRANTS. OF
MORE THAN NINETY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW MANY NOT ALL THE WORK
THAT CONSIGLIO. AND BECAUSE OF
THESE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
DONE A LOT OF IT IS AND BECAUSE
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET THAT KIND
OF FUNDING. IT JUST WASN'T
AVAILABLE EVEN THOUGH
FOUNDATIONS. AND INDIVIDUAL
DONORS WE'RE MUCH MORE TO. AND
STEPPING UP THEY CAN MATCH THE
POWER OF GOD TO DO KIND OF WORK.
SECONDLY WE NEED REALLY FROM
THAT ARE UNDERSTANDABLE IN THE
FIRST SET OF QUESTIONS OF
APPLICATIONS FOR THE RELIEF
PROGRAM THE FIRST QUESTION WAS
WHAT IS THE NAME OF THE OWNER.
NO THAT'S A PHRASE THAT KIND OF
MADE NONPROFIT STATE MAYBE I
DON'T BELONG HERE BECAUSE OF
COURSE BE NONPROFITS DON'T HAVE
OWNERS- WE ARE ALREADY IN EFFECT
BY THE PUBLIC SO WE NEED TO
LEAVE PROGRAMS THAT SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE. OF NONPROFITS AND
MAKES SENSE TO THEM SO THAT THEY
CAN SUCCESSFULLY FILL OUT THE
APPLICATIONS. AS SEVERAL PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED WE NEED CONTRACT
THAT'S ABILITY SOMETIMES FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE TO KEEP OUR
CHILDCARE SO. CHILDCARE CENTERS
OPEN FOR THE CHILDREN OF
EMERGENCY WORKERS BUT WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO MEET FOR EXAMPLE THE
DELIVERABLES OF THE NORMAL MARC
NORMAL ATTENDANCE RATES. UPON
WHICH OUR CONTRACTS WAS
DELIVERED AND OTHER TIMES WE
HAVE TO QUICKLY BE ABLE TO MOVE.
MONEY FROM ONE THING TO ANOTHER
WE SAW LOTS OF HEALTH CLINICS
HAVING TO MOVE LARGE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY. INTO MASKS AND SAFETY
EQUIPMENT- WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
THROUGH AND OFTEN THE BORI S.
AND TIME CONSUMING BUDGET
MODIFICATION PROCESS PROCESS. A
LOT OF TIMES GOVERNMENT RELIEF
ON COMES IN THE FORM OF INCOME
TAX CREDITS AND BECAUSE MOST
NONPROFITS DON'T PAY INCOME TAX
THAT'S WHAT TAXES IT MEANS. I'M
A PAYROLL TAX CREDITS ARE WHAT
ARE MORE IMPORTANT TO LAST AND
IN FACT THE E. R. T. SEATING
PLAN EMPLOYEE RETENTION.
SOMETHING THAT. ARE IN THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM DID IN FACT USE
PAYROLL TAX CREDITS AS AS WAYS
OF SUPPORTING BOTH SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS AND
IT'S A MUCH MORE EQUITABLE AND
FAIR WAY TO PROVIDE TAX CREDITS.
AND THEN FINALLY WE KNOW THAT
GOVERNMENT NEEDS A ROBUST IT
INDUSTRY AN ECOSYSTEM JUST LIKE
WE NEED A ROBUST AGRICULTURAL
SYSTEM AND SUPPLY CHAIN. WE ALSO
NEED THAT NONPROFITS AND IN
PARTICULAR WE KNOW THERE ARE
STILL MANY DISPARITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT PARTICULARLY IF
I MEAN IT GOES TO NONPROFIT AND
WE'RE AREAS INTO OUR AREA AND-
OF COLOR ARE SPENT. IMPORTANT
FOR ALL OF US. IS JUST COUPLE OF
ITS- YOU KNOW- FOR ONE OF THE
OUR RESEARCH HAS SHOWN IS THAT
FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT THE
METROPOLITAN NONPROFIT HAS A
RURAL NONPROFIT HAS FIFTY NINE
CENTS. THAT SHOWS THE DISPARITY
BETWEEN HOW GOVERNMENT
FOUNDATION AND INDIVIDUAL
FINDING IS- IN TERMS OF ALL OF
THESE AND THEN ONE LAST THING- I
MET MRS CONTRACTS THAT ALLOW
NONPROFITS TO COMPETE FOR
TALENT. THE AVERAGE AMOUNT THAT
OUR MEALS ON WHEELS GET THAT
CALIFORNIA MEALS ON WHEELS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE RECEIVED. FOR
A MEAL DELIVERED IS FIVE DOLLARS
AND FIVE CENTS PER DELIVERED
MEAL. AND IF YOU HAVE A CONTRACT
WITH THE GOVERNMENT THAT GIVES
YOU THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY. THE
ONLY THING YOU CAN DO IS PUSH
DOWN YOUR WAGES OFTEN TO A POINT
WHERE YOU CAN'T COMPETE WITH
OTHERS FOR TALENT AND ALSO THAT
JUST SIMPLY ISN'T FAIR TO OUR
EMPLOYEES. SO ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT THAT ARE SOME THAT
MANY PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE
ALREADY NOW. SO WE'RE VERY HAPPY
TO HAVE YOU IN AT AS ALLIES TO
CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THESE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING. THANK YOU. I'M
NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM JULIE
BAKER. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON TEARS REVERSAL IMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ARTS AND CULTURE
NONPROFITS IN CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THIS IAUGURAL HEARING MY NAME
IS JULIE BAKER MY PRONOUNS ARE
SHE HER HERS AND I'M COMING
TODAY FROM THE UNCEDED LAND AT
THE NEVADA CITY RANCHERIA NISSAN
OR NEVADA CITY CALIFORNIA. AND
I'M SPEAKING TODAY AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS IN
CALIFORNIA OUR TOPIC HITS THERE
ARE FIFTEEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY ARTS CULTURE AND
HUMANITIES NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
COMBINED THESE CALIFORNIA ARTS
CULTURE AND HUMANITIES
NONPROFITS EMPLOYS SEVENTY FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND THREE
PEOPLE EARN MORE THAN SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN REVENUE EACH
YEAR. WHEN HAVE ASSETS OF
NINETEEN BILLION DOLLARS BUT I
DON'T THINK I NEED TO SHARE THE
DEBIT STATION COVER THE HOUSE
CALLS FOR ARTS AND CULTURE
NONPROFITS I MEAN IMPACT WAS
ONLY A YEAR AGO THAT WE WERE
STILL SHUT DOWN AND IT IS
COMPLETELY UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
MAJOR DECISIONS MAY BE MADE IN
EMERGENCIES TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC IN OUR EXPERIENCE SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT HOW DECISIONS
ARE BEING MADE WHEN THEY AFFECT
ENTIRE SECTORS OF OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. THE EFFECTS
OF CODE OR LONG LASTING FOR THE
ARTS AND CULTURE SECTOR NOT
ATTENDANCE NUMBERS ARE NOT LIKE
THEY WERE PRE PANDEMIC NOW AND
EVEN THOUGH OTHER SECTORS SEEM
TO BE REBOUNDING WE ARE NOT YET.
IN RESPONSE TO THE CLOSURES MANY
NONPROFITS. IS IT ONLINE. BUT WE
KNOW THAT WITHOUT. TO THE RIGHT
. OR BROADBAND AS HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO THRIVE PROGRAMMING
OUTREACH WAS NOT EQUITABLE.
HOWEVER MANY COULD NOT RETREAT
TO ONLINE DELIVERY ARTS PROGRAM
BUT HAD TO PIVOT TO PROVIDING
OTHER CRITICAL IN PERSON
SERVICES AS WELL. INCLUDING
PUBLIC HEALTH EDUCATION CHILD
CARE AND FOOD DELIVERY. THE
SKILLS ARTS AND ARTS WORKERS
BRING SHOULD BRING SHOULD BE
RELIED ON DURING A CRISIS.
ARTISTS ARE SECOND RESPONDERS
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS AND ARTISTS
THING EIGHT YOU DON'T PLOY
INNOVATIVE ENTERED AND FLEXIBLE.
AND CREATIVE COMMUNICATORS. AS A
BENTON PUBLIC GATHERING
ORGANIZERS TO WE ARE TRAINING
CROWD MANAGEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND QUICKLY BUILDING TEMPORARY
STRUCTURES LIKE ONE DAY
FESTIVALS. ACCESS TO THE ARTS
WILL HELP US SURVIVE IN OVERCOME
THE PANDEMIC AND AS WE EMERGE
FROM THE CRISIS WILL BE A CHANGE
SOCIETY. INVESTMENT IN THE ARTS
NEED TO BE A PART OF A LONG TERM
STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH THE
AFTERMATH OF THE PANDEMIC.
REBUILDING CALIFORNIA WILL
REQUIRE INGENUITY INCLUDING A
RECKONING OF SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS
SUCH AS RACISM. ECONOMIC
DISPARITY. ARTS AND CULTURE
NONPROFITS ARE TRUSTED COMMUNITY
PARTNERS THAT UTILIZE ACCESS TO
ARTS AND CULTURE AND
PARTICIPATORY ART. AS A MEANS TO
ENGAGE USE AND EDUCATE YOUTH
BUILD SOCIAL COHESION CREATE
EMPATHY. AND HEALING FROM TRAUMA
THESE ARE CRITICAL SERVICES FOR
OUR COMMUNITY. BUT WE ALSO
LEARNED THAT ARTS WORKERS ARE
VULNERABLE WORK FORCE AND THE
PANDEMIC HAS HEIGHTENED THIS
VULNERABILITY AND HIGHLIGHTED
RACIAL INEQUITIES. AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE CRISIS 63% OF CREATIVE
WORKERS WERE UNEMPLOYED ONE IN
TEN HAVE EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AND ONE OF THREE HAVE FACED THE
THREAT OF INFECTION. 55% OF
WORKERS IN THE CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES HAVE NO SAVINGS TO
FALL BACK ON. AN ARTIST IN
DENTAL FIVE FIVE TALK HAVE
HIGHER RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
WHITE ARTISTS AND WANTS A LARGER
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR INCOME
DURING THE PANDEMIC. SO HERE
RESPECTFULLY OUR SUGGESTIONS IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IN
THESE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND HOW
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE BARRIERS
TO ACCESS FOR NEEDED RESOURCES.
LOOK TO YOUR ARTISTS AS CREATIVE
COMMUNICATORS AND PROBLEM
SOLVERS IN TIMES OF CRISIS. I
LOOKED ARTISAN OR AND TO HELP.
COMMUNITIES SECOND RESPONDERS
AFTER CRISIS INVEST IN THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ARTS WORKERS
GIVEN THE TOOLS TECHNICAL
TRAINING ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
AND EQUIPMENT TO BE PREPARED AND
READY TO SERVE. AS A STATE OF
NEW YORK JUST DID LET'S CREATE A
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT FOR
ARTISTS LET'S FUND THE
CALIFORNIA CREATIVE WORKFORCE
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
CREATE A NEW PIPELINE OF WORKERS
WITH DIVERSITY AND LIVING WAGES
AS PRIORITIES. ARE SOME PROFITS
ACROSS THE STREET OR WOEFULLY
UNDER CAPITALIZED WE NEED TO
FIND SUSTAINED GENERAL PERATING
SUPPORT AND NOT JUST SPECIAL ONE
TIME PROJECTS. AND INCREASE THE
STATE ARTS AGENCY CAL CORN ARTS
COUNCILS BASED ON BUDGET FROM
66% SIXTY SIX SIX CENTS PER
CAPITA TO ONE DOLLAR PER CAPITA.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
THE IMPACT OF AB FIVE ON SMALL
BUDGET PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND LOOK FOR
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO SUPPORT
THE ABILITY TO AFFORD HIRING
WORKERS WITH LIVING WAGES FOR
THESE VITAL COMMUNITY BOTH BASED
CULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS. THEY
WERE NOT THE INTENTION OF THIS
BILL BUT THEY ARE THE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE. GRANTMAKING SHOULD BE
ACCESSIBLE AND NOT DESIGNED FOR
ORGANIZATIONS WITH FULL TIME
PROFESSIONAL GRANT MAKERS. GRANT
APPLICATIONS NEED TO BE
STREAMLINED AND MADE COMMON
ACROSS AGENCIES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE AND FUNDING NEEDS TO BE
RELEASED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
AS YOU'VE BEEN HEARING. IN
ADDITION GRANT PERIOD SHOULD BE
OPEN LONGER UNTIL THE FUNDS ARE
EXPENDED AND INSTEAD OF CLOSING
ON A HARD STOP DATE. MANY ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE UNDERSTAFFED
OR EXPERIENCING THE REHIRING AND
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO APPLY
WITHIN THREE WEEKS AS OFTEN THEY
ARE ASKED WE ALSO SUGGEST
CREATING A STATEWIDE EQUITY
GOVERNMENT GRANTS REVIEW PANEL.
MADE UP OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
APPLIED DUE TO EITHER MISTRUST
FOR LACK OF CAPACITY TO REVIEW
CURRENT GRANT APPLICATIONS.
GRANT SHOULD BE ALWAYS BE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES
TO REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BUT AT LEAST ALL
SERVICES SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE IN SPANISH. WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALTHOUGH
NONPROFITS PROVIDE ECONOMIC
IMPACT LIKE A SMALL BUSINESS
THEY ARE ALSO DIFFER IN SO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUNDING NEED
TO TAKE TO ACCOUNT. THE
NONPROFITS ARE NOT EASILY
CHARACTERIZED BY NEXT CODES AND
FISK AND THAT FISCAL SPONSORED
ORGANIZATIONS UNDER A LARGE-
LARGER NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY.
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE SPACE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND LIVING
WAGES ARE CRITICAL ISSUES ARTS
NONPROFITS AND ARTS WORKERS.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING AND FOR
INCLUDING ARTS AND CULTURE AS A
NONPROFIT PROFITS AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- OUR NEXT SPEAKER IS
JENNIFER HARK CO. DO YOU WANT TO
ASK A QUESTION. GO AHEAD
ASSEMBLY MARKETS YEAH I WANNA
SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE- SUBMIT YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY WRITING BECAUSE I
WOULD LIKE TO EXTRACT SOME OF
THE IDEALS AND SOLUTIONS THAT
YOU'VE ARTICULATED I THINK
THEY'RE VERY GOOD SOLUTION SO
THAT'S THE ONLY POINT I WANT TO
MAKE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON
POINT. THANK YOU WE'RE LEARNING
SO MUCH FROM ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS
AND GETTING IDEAS- MAYBE FOR
FUTURE LEGISLATION- OTHER- OR
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR YOU KNOW THIS
IS OUR ARMED TOMORROW IS OUR
INTRODUCED OUR BILL INTRODUCTION
DEADLINE SO I KNOW SOMEONE FOR
GIBSON'S ALREADY MAKING A LIST
HERE RIGHT OF ALL THE IDEAS YEAH
I HAVE MY OWN LIST TOO SO- THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR LEADERS- NEXT.
JENNIFER HART CEO OF PEOPLE
ASSISTING THE HOMELESS PATH.
THANK YOU COACH JERRY BASS AND
CO CHAIR LIMÓN AND ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SO MUCH
FOR INVITING ME TO JOIN TODAY.
MY NAME'S JENNIFER HER KEITH AND
I'M HONORED TO BE THE CEO OF
PATH. HOW DOES THE NONPROFIT
HOMELESS SERVICE PROVIDER AND
HOUSING DEVELOPER WE STARTED
BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
AND LOS ANGELES AND I'VE GROWN
TO BE ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE BATTLING
THE CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS. DAY
WE NOW HAVE OVER SIXTY LOCATINS
WITH MAJOR COMMUNITY HUBS IN
SACRAMENTO SANTA BARBARA LOS
ANGELES LONG BEACH ORANGE COUNTY
AND SAN DIEGO. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
OVER TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
COMPLETED OR IN THE PIPELINE.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO END
HOMELESSNESS FOR INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. WITH
CLOSE TO A THOUSAND STAFF
SERVING OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS A YEAR
COVERED NINETEEN IMPACTED US
GREATLY. TODAY I WANT TO FOCUS
ON TWO AREAS FOR OPPORTUNITY AS
WE LOOK AT HOW THE PANDEMIC
IMPACTED THAT AS WELL AS MANY
OTHERS LIKE WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
AND HELP US PREPARE FOR THE
FUTURE. ONE AREAS ARE WORKFORCE
AND THE OTHERS ARE OF THE
CONTRACTING CHALLENGES. I WILL
START WITH THE CHALLENGES WE'VE
SEEN MAINTAINING OUR WORKFORCE.
GOING BACK TO MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY WHEN THE LOCKDOWN
OCCURRED WE KNEW INSTANTLY THAT
WE WERE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. I CAN
STILL REMEMBER EXACTLY WHERE I
WAS WHEN I HEARD THE NEWS OF THE
SHUTDOWN AS I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
CAN AS WELL. BUT WHAT THIS TRULY
MET FOR US WAS THAT AS THE REST
OF THE WORLD WAS FIGURING OUT
HOW THE IMPLICATIONS WOULD. WORK
WITH THEIR FAMILY OR HOW THEY
WOULD MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS
WITH FOOD AND PAPER GOODS
SHORTAGES. OUR ENTIRE TEAM HAD
TO THINK THROUGH THIS FOR
THOUSANDS OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS WE SIR. AND WE DID.
OUR TEAM SET UP THIRTEEN NEW
INTERN HOUSING SITES IN LESS
THAN SIX MONTHS. MANY OF THEM
WITHIN DAYS OF TOURING THE
FACILITY. WE KNEW THAT IT WAS
TRULY LIFE OR DEATH. HOWEVER AND
THIS TOOK A GREAT TOLL ON THE
STAFF WITH OFTEN LITTLE OR NO
COMPENSATION INCREASED. IT'S NOT
LOST ON ME THAT OUR SECTOR IS
SEEING A SIGNIFICANT TURNOVER.
ONLY SERVICE HAS ALWAYS HAD A
HEALTHCARE ROLE. ENTERING HOLDEN
WE REALLY PUSH THAT TO THE LIMIT
. HAVING STAFF WORK DIRECTLY
WITH COMMON POSITIVE
PARTICIPANTS PROVIDING TESTING
BREEDING THOSE ESSENTIAL ITEMS
INTO THE COMMUNITY. WITHOUT A
LOT OF TRAINING WITHOUT
IDENTIFYING WHAT EXPERTISE THEY
NEEDED. AS AN EXAMPLE WE HIRED
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
PEOPLE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE. WE HAD OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN STAFF
LEAVE THE ORGANIZATION AND WE DO
AN EXIT INTERVIEW WITH EVERY
PERSON. ALMOST ALL OF THEM CITED
THEY WERE LEAVING OUR SECTOR.
AND THE MAJORITY OVER 75% OF THE
SEPARATIONS AND BARELY BEEN WITH
US HERE. SO WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO INVEST IN THE STAFF
WHO NEVER GAVE UP TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE OUTREACH RUN INTERIM
HOUSING AND BE THE HOPE FOR
PEOPLE WHO OFTEN DON'T HAVE ANY.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT OUR WORK
FORCE DIFFERENTLY AND ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THE
WELLNESS PROGRAMS AND THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT OUR TEAMS
RIGHTFULLY DESERVE. AND THE
SECOND AREA WE WANT TO FOCUS ON
IS REALLY PREPARING AROUND OUR
CONTRACT CHALLENGES. THE FIRST
ONE IS PAY EQUITY AND I THINK IT
REALLY TIES INTO THE WORK FORCE
CHALLENGES. HEALTHCARE IS ONE OF
THE LEADING INDUSTRIES PEOPLE
ARE LEAVING. WE NEED TO PROVIDE
A LEAVE LIVING WAGE WHERE PEOPLE
CAN LIVE AND WORK IN THE SAME
COMMUNITY. AND OUR STAFF CAN NOT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE SAME
SERVICES THAT THEY OFFER
PARTICIPANTS. WE DON'T WANT TO
PERPETUATE POVERTY. THIS HAS
COME TO LIGHT EVER EVEN MORE
THAN EVER DURING THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. BY SETTING ANNUAL
INCREASES FOR MULTI YEAR
CONTRACTS. AND SETTING PAY
STANDARDS BY REGIONAL COST OF
LIVING STANDARDS. THIS CAN HELP
RETAIN STAFF IN OUR FIELD.
ANOTHER ITEM AS DAN MENTIONED IS
FULL COST FUNDING. TRULY PAYING
FOR THE FULL COST OF PROVIDING
THE SERVICE. OFTEN NONPROFITS
HAVE TO FUNDRAISE TO COVER
EXPENSES CONTRACTS DO NOT
PROVIDE. LET'S FUNDRAISE FOR
INNOVATION NOT BASIC MEANS.
DURING KOBE AND WE HAVE HAD
JANITORIAL COSTS TRIPLE IN SOME
OF OUR INTERN HOUSING AND
SHELTER FACILITIES. WITHOUT ANY
INCREASE GOVERNMENT REVENUE.
CONTRACTS NEED TO BE RE
EVALUATED FOR TRUE COSTS THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONTRACTED BEYONCE'S
WE SHOULD NOT BE WAITING FOR
LENGTHY REIMBURSEMENTS AND SOME
OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
FIGURE THIS OUT. ADDITIONALLY
ALLOWING FLEXIBILITY BETWEEN THE
LINE ITEMS IT'S BEEN STATED
SPECIALLY DURING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WOULD ALLOW US OFTEN
THE SAFETY NET AND COMMUNITIES
TO ADAPT TO THE EMERGENCY
WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT CLOSING
OUR DOORS. WE NEED TO LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAPACITY
BUILDING I KNOW THAT NOT
EVERYONE WANTS TO FUND CAPACITY
BUILDING. BUT WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THAT THIS WOULD GREATLY INCREASE
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND QUICKLY.
MANY OF US GREW DURING THE
PANDEMIC NOT BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO BUT BECAUSE WE ROSE TO THE
CHALLENGE. AND YET THIS QUICK
GROWTH CAUSES A RACE TO KEEP UP
WITH THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
NEEDED TO SUPPORT OUR PROGRAMS.
THE SUMMARIZE WE LEARNED SO MUCH
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE CHANGES. NOW
WE HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY- THAT
WILL BETTER PREPARE US FOR THE
FUTURE. SO LET'S NOT GET STUCK
UNPREPARED AGAIN LET'S PLAN FOR
THE NEXT EMERGENCY BECAUSE WE
KNOW WHEN OUT MORE THAN EVER.
THAT WE WILL NEED TAX SWIFTLY
AND THEN OUR NONPROFIT SECTOR
WILL CONTINUE TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITY. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU ALL TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU JENNIFER- OUR
LAST SPEAKER ON THIS PANEL. WE
HAVE DOCTOR LEON DROPPED CLARK
HARVEY CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES. THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM
ACTUALLY NOT A THIRD PARTY AND
IDEOLOGIST AND I AM C. O. C. H.
I. WE REPRESENT MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE TO OR AGENCIES
THAT SERVE OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ANNUALLY
AND THERE'S BEEN SOME REALLY
ILLUMINATING DISCUSSION TODAY
ABOUT THE SERVICES THAT
NONPROFITS PROVIDE AND I'D LIKE
TO DISCUSS THE PEOPLE BEHIND
THEM SERVICES. THE ROIC
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK DAY IN AND
DAY OUT TO PROVIDE THESE
ESSENTIAL SERVICE SO OUR MEMBERS
HAVE BRAVE THIS PANDEMIC TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO SO MANY WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS BUT IT'S
COME AT A COST IT'S COME AT A
COST TO THEIR PRODUCTIVITY THEIR
PERSONAL SAFETY AND MANY
AGENCIES ARE ON THE BRINK OF
CRISIS DUE TO THE VERY SEVERE
WORK FOR SHORTNESS OF BREATH.
SENATE CVHS THE STATE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION HAS A FIFTEEN OUR
MEMBERS WITH GRANTS FOR
TELEHEALTH EQUIPMENT PP AND
CONSTANT ADVOCACY BUT MORE IS
NEEDED THE EXTRA PAINTING IS NOT
PLEASANT BUT THE STORY HAS TO BE
TOLD AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
HAVE TO FIND SOLUTIONS SO THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ESSENTIAL
PERSONNEL AND OUR PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE
RETAINED. AND RECRUITED AND
CLIENTS ARE SERVED TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ARE FACING A
UNIQUE SET OF CHALLENGES AND
IT'S NO SURPRISE TO MANY HERE
THAT AT THE HEART OF IT ALL ALL
IS FINANCING. IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE OUR AGENCIES EXIST.
OFTEN VERY FUNDING SOURCES. FOR
MANY THEIR POWER. PHONE STREAM
COMES KANT WITH BE HEALTH DURING
THIS CRISIS SOME OF OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS HAVE WORKED TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY WITH UP FRONT
PAYMENTS IN NEGOTIATE SHIPPING
CONTRACTS AROUND REIMBURSEMENT
RATES. BUT THERE IS GREAT
INCONSISTENCY LEAVING SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS TO QUESTION IF THEY
CAN SURVIVE OFF OF EXISTING
RATE. HAS BEEN MENTIONED BY
COLLEAGUES FROM OTHER SECTORS
TODAY WORKFORCE HAS AND ALWAYS
WILL BE OUR TOP PRIORITY POLICY
AT PRIORITY AND WHILE WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFORDED WITH THE
USE OF TELEHEALTH. THERE ARE
ALSO CHECK ALLEN JEFF IT IS NOT
THE BEST MODALITY FOR ALL
POPULATIONS AND WITH THE SURGEON
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TECHNOLOGY WHAT
DO YOU IT WARRANTS GREATER
SAFEGUARDS AND QUALITY CONTROL
FOR EXAMPLE I'M CONSUMER NOTE.
IF AN APP IS GOOD OR NOT OR WILL
SOLVE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH CARE
ADEQUATELY AND INDICATEIF THEY
HAVE A TRUE DENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
AND MANY PRIVATE TECH COMPANIES
ARE NOW RECRUITING STAFF FROM
THE PUBLIC BE ABLE TO HELP.
BECAUSE OF OR RATES AND AN
ABILITY TO PAY THEM WHILE. CBO
STAFF ARE UNDERPAID THERE OVER
WORK YET THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES
TO CREATE MORE PEOPLE HEALTH
NEEDS. TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND
HIS PARENTS TRANSITION BACK TO
WORK. FOR THOSE AGENCIES WHO ARE
LOOKING TO BE CALM CERTIFIED TO
PROVIDE MEDICAL SERVICES I'VE
HEARD FROM MANY ESPECIALLY BY
PARKS SERVING AGENCIES IN SMALL
AREAS THAT SOME ENCOUNTER
BARRIERS IN A CUMBERSOME
CERTIFICATION PROCESS AT THE
STATELEVEL. AND OUR STATE HAS
NOT BEEN THE MOST FRIENDLY TO
OUT OF STATE PROVIDERS WHO LOOK
TO YOU TRANSACTION ARE LICENSES
THE CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
BOLSTER ARE ALREADY LACKING
WORKFORCE. LAST WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHO POPULOUS ARE WORKFORCE THEY
WERE NONPROFITS LEAD THE WAY
WITH BOARD DIVERSITY HAS BEEN
SHARED EARLIER WE NEED TO
INCREASE THE EVEN MORE SO FROM
THE BOARDS OF OUR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO THE CLINICIANS
AND. THE CLIENTS THEY SERVE SO
IN SOME THERE'S AN OF ISSUE THAT
I'VE OUT. BY HERE ARE SOME. ONE
ARE. NEED TO HAVE TO GO. RATE
LET ME BUT THERE CAN TO ACCOUNT
FOR CHANGES MINIMUM WAGE THE
DIRE WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND TO
ALLOW FOR MORE COMPETITIVE WAGES
FOR RETAINING AND RECRUITING
WORKFORCE. OUR STATE SHOULD
EXPLORE FLEXIBILITY EVEN LICENSE
RECIPROCITY WITH NEIGHBORING
STATES. WE NEED QUALITY CONTROL
AND ASSESSMENT OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TECHNOLOGY. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT BARRIERS TO BECOMING
A MEDICAL PROVIDER OR ELIMINATED
AND WE NEED TO INVEST IN
RECRUITMENT HAVE DIVERSE
NONPROFIT BOARD. LEADERSHIP AND
STAFF. NOW WE REALIZE THAT THE
SOLUTIONS CANNOT BE PERSONAL
LOAN BUT ONLY IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH. ANY STATE AND EVEN PRIVATE
SECTOR ALLIES. AS THE CHAIRWOMAN
SO IS TO LEAVE COMMENTED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
NONPROFITS ARE THE HEART AND THE
BACKBONE BUT WE'VE BEEN LEFT
BEHIND. AND AS MICHAEL PRISONER
FROM THE FIRST PANEL STATED
NONPROFITS ARE A POWERFUL FORCE
FOR EQUITY WE ARE IN A PHYSICAL
AND EMOTIONAL CRISIS AND WE NEED
OUR ESSENTIAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS. READY TO
ASSIST US WITH THE EMOTIONAL
TOLL OF THIS PANDEMIC THANK YOU
FOR HIGHLIGHTING. THE STATE OF
AFFAIRS OF NONPROFITS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH ARE. ALL GREAT
PRESENTATIONS WITH GREAT IDEAS-
FOR US AND FOR WHAT THE STATE
CAN DO BETTER TO SUPPORT. OUR
NON PROFITS THAT ARE VERY
CRITICAL ESPECIALLY DURING
EMERGENCIES- NEXT I WILL OPEN UP
TO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YES IF I
WOULD JUST ASK THE SAME THING
THAT I HAS PREVIOUS IF ALL THE
PRESENTERS CAN PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR SOLUTIONS- YOUR TESTIMONIES
TO WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE SO
THAT WE CAN GET A COPY OF IT-
BECAUSE- THERE'S SOME THINGS
THAT I CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE I CAPTURE. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO COLLABORATING WITH YOU ON
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES IN WHICH YOU BROUGHT UP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DAHLE
PADDLE. SENATOR THE MONTH THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND I. WOULD
LIKE TO AGAIN THANK THINK FOLKS
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW LISTENING
TO TWO OF TWO THIS LAST PANEL-
CERTAINLY A FEEL LIKE. TRYING TO
IDENTIFY HOW WE ADDRESS THE
ISSUES- OF REIMBURSEMENT RATES
IT IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT-
ADDITIONALLY THE DIFFERENCES I
WAS REALLY STRUCK BY ONE OF THE-
DATA PIECES THAT WE SHARED. THAT
TO- TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW IN IN
KIND OF RURAL. COMMUNITIES IN
ITS FIFTY NINE CENTS TO THE
DOLLAR FOR WHAT URBAN NONPROFITS
GET AND I'M A AND MAY HAVE
GOTTEN THAT SLIGHTLY INACCURATE
BUT I THINK THAT. THAT'S WHAT MY
NOTES SAY THAT'S WHAT I TOOK
DOWN. AND THAT'S VERY REAL
BECAUSE THERE'S OTHER CHALLENGES
THAT COME IN SO- I KNOW FOR
THOSE OF US THAT HAVE SOME.
RURAL COMMUNITIES WE CERTAINLY
LOOK AT THAT AS WELL- AND WE
WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW. EVEN
WITHIN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR- HOW
WE HEAR HOW WE ADDRESS EQUITY
ISSUES- BECAUSE THE ISSUES ARE
CERTAINLY DIFFERENT- BUT THERE
ARE. BUT POOR IS POOR WHETHER
YOU'RE IN URBAN OR WHETHER
YOU'RE IN RURAL. IF YOU CANNOT
AFFORD FOOD ON THE TABLE THE
FEELING IS VERY SIMILAR RATE IF
YOU CANNOT AFFORD- I HEALTH OVER
YOUR ROOF- THAT'S GOING TO
IMPACT YOU- AS WELL SO- I LOOK
FORWARD TO. AGAIN IN FUTURE
ECONOMY IN. FUTURE- HEARINGS AND
- OTHER PLACE WHERE WE CAN MORE
INFORMATION CAN HAVE A DIALOGUE
TO INCLUDE THOSE TWO ITEMS IN
OUR DISCUSSION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I OF COURSE LEARNED SO MUCH
FROM THIS PANEL AND WE KEEP
HEARING THE RECURRENT ISSUE OF
REIMBURSEMENT FROM STATE
CONTRACTS AND- THE DELAYS.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR OUR NON
PROFITS TO RECEIVE THIS FUNDING
THAT THEY HAVE TO PUT UP FRONT
SOMEHOW EITHER THROUGH CREDIT
LINE OR ANOTHER WAY- AND- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE PRESENTERS
TALKED ABOUT. OFFERING
POTENTIALLY A PAYROLL TAX CREDIT
TO NONPROFITS WE DO THAT A LOT
IN THE LEGISLATURE WHERE WE
OFFER TAX CREDITS. INCOME TAX
CREDITS TO INDUSTRIES THAT WE
WANT TO KEEP IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WE THINK ARE CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIA- A YOU KNOW WE WANT
THAT IN CALIFORNIA BUT WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT FOR NON PROFITS. AND
YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
KNOW I SERVE ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVAN TAX COMMITTEE SO I HEAR ON
THESE BILLS. R. AS IMPORTANT BUT
WE NEED TO THIS IS ONE WAY TO
ELEVATE THE NONPROFIT SECTOR AND
ALSO CONSIDER THEM AS IMPORTANT
AS OTHER INDUSTRIES IN OUR AND
OUR JOINT AUTHORS. OKAY OKAY.
AUTHORS HERE. YES THIS IS A
GREAT WAY I HAD NEVER THOUGHT OF
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T I WAS THE
GO OTHER TAX EXEMPT RIGHT A LOT
OF US THINK OF NON PROFITS AS
YOU KNOW THE AS TAX EXEMPT BUT
AT NOW THAT REMINDED ME WE HAVE
TO STILL SUBMIT PARA NO ONE IS
TAX EXEMPT OF PAYROLL TAXES AND
IN THE STATE R. M. IT TO THAT
ALSO I THOUGHT OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE NONPROFIT WORK FORCE AND
SUPPORTING YOU KNOW LIKE EVERY
LIKE LOTS OF OTHER INDUSTRIES.
THIS INDUSTRY IS ALSO FACING A
WORK FOR SHORTAGE OR YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE. ARE BECOMING LESS
MOTIVATED BECAUSE OF THE
CONDITION THE WORKING
CONDITIONS. AND THE STRESS THAT.
OF ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC THAT. THEY MAY BE
FACING AS A SERVICE PROVIDER AND
WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT. PEOPLE STILL WANT TO ENTER
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW THAT IT IS.
A VERY REWARDING CAREER- FOR ALL
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR OLDER
PEOPLE- EXPERIENCED WORKERS- SO
THANK YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING ALL
OF THESE ISSUES- TO BOTH PANELS.
NEXT I WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. IF WE HAVE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE
LINES. DO WE HAVE. PHONE LINES
OPEN. OKAY. AS OUR MODERATOR
READY IF THERE ARE ANY. YES IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY OVER THE PHONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO. AND
FIRST WE WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. CARAMON IN
REVERSING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING A
CONVERSATION ON IMPACT
NONPROFITS DURING EMERGENCY I'M
BROUGH TO ALL OF THE GREAT
PANELISTS. MY NAME IS JEANINE
HOLDERS BDO THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION WE'VE ALREADY
SUBMITTED A LETTER BUT I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON A COUPLE ISSUES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE A. P.
NONPROFIT. A NONPROFIT SIGN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HAVE A
STATE CONTRACTOR COURT INCOME
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES. WITH
ENROLLMENT NOT THAT THE
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE THESE
NONPROFITS WHO ARE CONTRACTED BY
THIRTY EIGHT COUNTY TO
ADMINISTER THEIR CAL WORK STAGE
ONE CHILD CARE. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THESE EIGHTEEN
NONPROFITS WERE NOT PROVIDED ANY
FUNDING TO PROVIDE. A NEW
COMMERCIAL WORK ENVIRONMENT YET
WE'RE EXPECTED TO MAINTAIN
CONTINUAL CONTACT WITH ENROLLED
FAMILIES. ELEAZER ANOTHER WERE
PROVIDED FUNDING TO BE CLOSED
DURING THE EMERGENCY AND YET THE
EIGHTEEN NONPROFIT THAT HAD A
CRITICAL ROLE TO CONTINUE
MEETING WITH FAMILIES. AND TAKE
ON THE NEW WORK LOAD- AND
ROLLING ASCENTIAL WORKERS HAD TO
SECURE PERSONAL LINES OF CREDIT
IN ORDER TO KEEP THIRTEEN
FAMILY. CURRENTLY THESE
NONPROFIT THAT ARE LIKE MINDED
SO MANY FRAGILE FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING JUST AS ALL OTHER
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA THEY
ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE HUGE
LOCKED IN OUR WORKFORCE. HOWEVER
THERE STATE CONTRACT WITH THE
NONPROFIT PROHIBITS THEM FROM
OFFERING SUCH THINGS AS HIRING
BONUSES OR FLEXIBILITY TO
INCREASE EXISTING STAFF SALARIES
THIS NEED IT. FINALLY I
UNDERSCORE THAT BECAUSE HE'S
RECEIVED NO HELP DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE FALLOUT IN THE
STRUGGLE FOR THESE PROGRAMS OF
WHICH SOME MAY NOT SURVIVE. SO
NOW WE'RE TASKED WITH ENROLLING
A HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS
FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
PROPOSED IN THIS FISCAL YEAR.
AND THE EIGHTY ADD THE
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY HOURS OF
POTENTIAL COVERED RELATED SICKLY. I UNDERSCORE ALL THE AS AND
LET YOU KNOW THAT THE CRISIS
FROM PANDA IS ON GOING. WE THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND WE HELP YOU
LOOK FOR SUPPORT FOR ANY THANK.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT. CHARLAMAGNE ENSURE
WE'VE GOT GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS WENDY **** REPRESENTING
SYCAMORE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WITH NINE LOCATIONS
OF CHARACTER AT L. A. COUNTY
NOTABLY IN THE THIRTY NINTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SINCE THE
START OF KOBE SYCAMORE STAFF
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE NEEDED
MENTAL HEALTH CARE CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. PORT RICHEY YOUNGER
AND ADULTS. MANY TOP PRIORITY
THE NEEDS OF OUR CONSUMERS AND
THE ORGANIZATION ABOUT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THEIR OWN
FAMILY. LIKE OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER PROFESSIONAL FIRST
RESPONDERS AND TEACHERS ARE
STAFF IN THE FACE OF FATIGUE AND
BURNOUT ARE STILL ON THE FRONT
LINES SERVING OUR COMMUNITY. YET
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
STRUGGLING TO REMAIN FINANCIALLY
VIABLE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURES IN THE PUBLIC
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND A
MEDIC CAL AND LOCAL CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS. YOUR FOR
NONPROFITS ABILITY TO ATTRACT
AND RETAIN HIGH QUALITY STAFF IN
COMPARISON TO OUR COMPETITORS IF
NONPROFIT ARE TO THRIVE POST
PANDEMIC THERE MUST BE IMMEDIATE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FROM LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWMAKERS. TO
HELP US KEEP OUR DOORS OPEN HELP
US CONTINUE TO OFFER LIFESAVING
CARE AND SUPPORT IN OUR
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. BLIND
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ADRIAN
SHELTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE REPRESENT A HUNDRED
SIXTY NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE WHO
ARE PROVIDING SERVICES TO
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN
PUBLIC HUMAN SERVICES SYSTEMS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE
LEADERSHIP FROM THE SELECT
COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING ON SUCH A
VITAL HEARING ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS AND ISSUES OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
IT IS TIMELY AND THE DISCUSSIONS
HAVE BEEN RICH AND IMPORTANT.
ARE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
SERVED A CRITICAL ROLE DURING
THE PANDEMIC. PROVIDING ENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHEN SCHOOLS WERE
CLOSED AS AN EXAMPLE. WHAT MOST
OF THE WORLD CLOSE DOWN OUR
MEMBERS WERE ALL OPERATING TO
SERVE A BOULDER OPAL POPULATION.
HAS BEEN EVEN MORE DEVASTATED BY
THE PANDEMIC. ONE SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THE STATE COULD
BE HELPFUL IN SUPPORTING
NONPROFITS. IS SUPPORTING THEM
FINANCIALLY AS POLICIES ROLL OUT
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT IMPACT
THEM IN TERMS OF COST.
SUPPORTING THEM SO THAT THEY CAN
SUPPORT THEIR WORK ORCE WHO ARE
DELIVERING THE SERVICES ACROSS
THE STATE. WORKFORCE CHALLENGES
PERSIST FOR OUR MEMBERS. SO WE
NEED TO EXPLORE EVERY POSSIBLE
AVENUE TO ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO
ENTER OUR WORKFORCE ADDED
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE THAT WE
HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
TWENTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THING COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT
THAT ARE SENT BY PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY OF THE GOVERNMENT
SERVICES WE STATEWIDE CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND FOSTER CARE
AGENCY THAT OPERATES IN FIVE
GEOGRAPHICAL REGIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE ARE NOW IN TWO
YEARS INTO THE PANDEMIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE EXPERIENCING THAT
COMPOUNDED WEIGHT OF THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. THEY CONTINUE
TO HAVE HORRIFICALLY PROVIDES
CRITICAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES.
STRUGGLING WITH TRAUMA AND OTHER
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES AND HELP
IN MEDICAID SERVICES- IN AND
RESOURCES INTO SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. NEEDS
ARE GREAT AND IT'S A TALL ORDER
FOR EMPLOYEES TO CARRY OUT. OR
NOT AND FATIGUE IS REAL AND WE
SEE ITS IMPACT IN THE WORK FORCE
RETENTION. WE NEED IMMEDIATE
INTERMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS AND STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THE WAR COURT. AND
PIPELINE ISSUE. YOU'RE A WE HAVE
AND RETAIN THE- AND CULTURALLY
WORKFORCE OF TODAY. AND OF THE
FUTURE. WE APPRECIATE IT AND
THAT COLLEAGUES LEAD WITH PATH
WHICH WE SUPPORT HOWEVER THERE
WAS NO FUNDING TO REIMBURSE
NONPROFIT FOR THE COST. CBO
MOSCOW THE CORRESPONDING FUNDING
TO FULLY CARRY OUT THE EXTENDED
BENEFIT. FINALLY WE ARE IN NEED
OF ROBUST REPAYMENT PROGRAM.
SCHOLARSHIP AND REGULATORY
BELIEVE. PARTICULAR AROUND
DOCUMENTATION. AND WE MUST
EXPLORE EVERY SINGLE AVENUE WE
HAVE TO SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY
BASED AGENCY WORKFORCE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY AT. THE HISTORIC HEARING.
LINE TWENTY. SHARE WITH US I'M
PRETTY RETRAIN PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
NONPROFITS ARE PLAYING A CENTRAL
ROLE IN KEEPING CALIFORNIANS
HEALTHY DURING THE PANDEMIC AS
THEY HAVE DONE FOR YEARS YEAH
AND WE'VE ALSO HEARD FROM EVERY
SPEAKER INADEQUATE INFLEXIBLE
STOP AND GO FUNDING PREVENTS NON
PROFIT FROM OPERATING AND
EXPANDING IT SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
THESE PROGRAMS OFTEN SHUT DOWN
ALTOGETHER WHEN FUNDING STOPPED
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON IS
CHAMPIONING A BUDGET REQUEST OF
ONE HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING TO
CREATE A HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND THAT WOULD
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
CLINICS AND TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS
WHY DON'T APPLY THE MOST
PRESSING INEQUITIES AND
INJUSTICES. IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND TAYLOR BEST PRACTICES TO
ADDRESS THEM. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE TRUSTED
RELATIONSHIPS AND KNOWLEDGE OF
COMMUNITY NEEDS THAT MAKES THE
FINANCIAL PARTNERS TO ADDRESS
UNFAIR PREVENTABLE DIFFERENCES
IN HEALTH OUTCOMES I REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT THE HEALTH EQUITY
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND WHICH WILL
BE A GAME CHANGER IN SUSTAINING
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS OVER THE
LONG TERM. TO ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE IN
COMMUNITIES. ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH REVERSE
LIMÓN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A SOME OF THEM AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY A
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES ONE OF
THE STATE'S LEADING HEALTH
INEQUITY ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
PUBLIC CITIZEN GODLY THIS BODY
ON THIS INAUGURAL MEETING AND
HIGHLIGHT THE VERY REAL NEED FOR
NONPROFITS TO BE SUPPORTED GO TO
FUNDING AND INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
THE FACE OF FUTURE EMERGENCIES.
I NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COMMONLY THE
FIRST LINE OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
IN OUR COMMUNITY. ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
AND STRUCTURALLY DISADVANTAGED.
BECAUSE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HIGHLIGHTED MANY HOLES IN OUR
SIXTY STRUCTURE AS THEY RELATE
TO THE LINE OF COMMUNICATION
ESTABLISHED BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
AND OUR NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. AND HOW
THAT AFFECTED THIS WITNESS. IN
RESPONSE TO FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR THE COMMUNITY THAT STATE.
ADDITIONALLY THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC EXPOSED MANY
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE STRUCTURE
THAT NONPROFITS ARE FORCED TO
EMPLOY DUE TO THE LACK OF
SUPPORT. I GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
OFTEN BEING FORCED TO TAKE A
RESPONSIVE AND REACTIVE APPROACH
TO MEET THE EMERGENCY NEEDS THAT
THE COMMUNITY THEY REPRESENT
SAFE DURING EMERGENCY CRISES.
WHAT WE NEED ARE PROACTIVE AND
LONG TERM INVESTMENTS IN
ENSURING THAT HEALTH EQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE ARE ACHIEVED IN
THE FACE OF EMERGENCY. CRISES
THERE ARE MANY BUILDING BUDGET
US BEING HIGHLIGHTED THIS YEAR
THAT AIM TO ADDRESS THIS
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND WE'RETO THIS COMMITTEE AND
ITS MEMBERS TO CONTINUE TO LEARN
AND ASK FOR HELP. AND
INFORMATION AS YOU'RE DOING
TODAY CENTERING THE MOST
IMPACTED ENTITIES THAT THIS
CONVERSATION OF FACTS AND OUR
LENDING. OUR EXPERIENCES AND
EXPERTISE ON THE GROUND TO HELP
MEET THE NEEDS THAT THE NEEDS
PRESENTED. REGARDING GAUGE OF
THIS BODY HAS ALL OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AT LARGE TO UPLIFT
THE GREATEST BARRIERS TO
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION THROUGH
NONPROFIT INVOLVEMENT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. AND COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
THANK YOU. LINE AT TWENTY NINE.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DR WENDEL BRUNNER AND FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS I WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY HEALTH
SERVICES. I STILL CONTINUE TO
WORK IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CHRONIC DISEASE AND COBIT ALL
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NONPROFITS ARE VITAL TO THE WORK
THAT WE DO IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
. OKAY SHIPS BETWEEN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND OTHERS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO APPROVED IMPROVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND TO ADDRESS
THE HEALTH INEQUITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT THE ANDEMIC
HAS SO STARKLY ILLUMINATED. YES
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT YOU DO
NEED MORE RESOURCE TO ADDRESS
THE MAJOR HEALTH PROBLEMS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT WE ALSO NEED
RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN COURT STRONG COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND NONPROFITS AND
DETERMINE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ADDRESS THE HEALTH PROBLEMS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND ADDRESS
HEALTH INEQUITIES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR HOPE THAT COULD
BE IN RACIAL JUSTICE ONE OR
OTHER APPROPRIATE WAYS OF
FUNDING COMMUNITY BASED ND NON
PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK ON
HEALTH AND HEALTH EQUITY THANK
YOU. BLINDED. THIRTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRS RIVAS AND
WE MONNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BENITO DELGADO OLSON AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE NONPROFIT SUPPLY BANK .ORG.
I THINK DOT ORG WORKS WITH MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO ENSURE THEY HAVE
THE ESSENTIAL MATERIALS SUPPLIED
THAT THEIR CONSTITUENCIES AND
PEOPLE NEED FOR HEALTH. AND
OVERALL WELL BEING. SINCE THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC SUPPLY I
THINK THAT'LL WORK FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA FEE AT THE CALLAWAY
AT FEMA. AND LOCAL AGENCIES IN
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES WORKS
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THOUSANDS OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS NONPROFITS
WITH MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ITEMS OF PP. TWENTY
MILLION DIAPERS FIFTY MILLION
WHITES AND ALSO ADDITIONAL
CENTRAL FOR THOSE WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY THE WILDFIRES.
WITHOUT QUESTION NONPROFIT
STEPPED UP DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE GOVERNMENT SUPPORT FOR
NONPROFITS ARE NOW MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER. MANY
ACTIONS ARE NEEDED AND WE
SINCERELY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND PUTTING TOGETHER
TODAY'S PENSION HEARING IT IS A
GREAT START. WOULD LIKE TO ECHO
THE SPEAKER ON CHILD CARE
SUPPORT AND ALSO PANELISTS KAREN
DELANEY'S COMIC ON THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT LINE OF CREDIT.
PROVIDE. ON TO NON PROFITS
BOTTOM LINE. APPLY THINK .ORG
THE NATIONAL BANK NETWORK ALSO
SEEKING THIRTY MILLION IN THIS
YEAR'S TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET OVER THREE YEARS TO FUND
STAKE BY DIAPERED INVITE
DISTRIBUTION. TO CREATE A
STATEWIDE FOOTPRINT FROM THE
EXISTING PROGRAM. WE'RE PLEASED
TO BE WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES ON THIS
REQUEST. IS AN ORGANIZATION WE
BELIEVE OUR PARTNERS WHEN THEY
SAY THAT ELIMINATING THE
PHYSICAL MATERIAL POVERTY ONE
EXPERIENCES WHEN CRISIS WERE
DISPLACED BY A WILDFIRE. GOES A
LONG WAY TOWARD ENDING THE
POVERTY OF THE SPIRIT ENABLING
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND A HAPPY
AND HEALTHY LIFE. WE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AGAIN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN CREATING THE SPACE
FOR NONPROFITS TO TALK SAFELY
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. A LINE. THIRTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATHY
WAYNE AND I AM THE BOARD CHAIR
OF FIRST RESPONDERS RESILIENCY
AND SONOMA COUNTY AND I THINK
YOU COMMITTEE CHAIRS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BE BUSTIN SENATOR LEON AS
WELL AS THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE ORGANIZATION THAT
WE SERVE IT IS- WE- CATER TO
BOTH RETIRED AND ACTIVE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND IT INCLUDES- FIRE PERSONNEL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL PERSONNEL LAW
ENFORCEMENT DISPATCH EMERGENCY
ROOM DOCTORS AND NURSES. ANY ANY
OTHER ESSENTIAL FRONTLINE
WORKERS- OUR GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
A PROACTIVE SCIENCE BASED
APPROACH TO THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
PHYSIOLOGICAL EFFECTS OF STRESS
AND COMMON FIRST RESPONDERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES- WE STARTED OUR
ORGANIZATION BACK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE HAD NO IDEA HOW
MUCH OF AN IMPACT THAT CODE
WOULD HAVE ON OUR ORGANIZATION
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE BEING IN
CINEMA COUNTY WITH ALL THE
MULTITUDE OF FIRES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH THE CODE
THAT. AS A MATTER OF FACT ONE OF
THE FIRST A COPE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEATHS HAPPENED IN
THE- SANTA ROSA WITH DETECTIVE
MARY LOU ARMOR WHO DIED AND- YOU
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
RESPONDING TO INCIDENTS THAT YOU
KNOW- WHAT YOU'RE RESPONDING TO
ON THERE WAS A THIS THE GREAT
UNKNOWN AS WELL AS YOU KNOW WE
SEE WITH MANY OF THE OTHER NON
PROPERTY SPOKE TODAY ON THAT
THEIR WORKERS CONTINUE TO COME
TO WORK REGARDLESS OF THE- THE
CHANCE THAT THEY COULD BE
EXPOSED TO. TO COPE WITH- WITH-
MANY OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS
THEIR FAMILIES ARE ALSO IMPACTED
WE HAD MANY OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO ACTUALLY LOST
THEIR HOMES AND MANY OTHER FIRES
AND THAT WE DON'T REALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT GOES ON
OUTSIDE OF THE GROUP PLAYS WE
KNOW WHAT THEY DO ON THE JOB BUT
IT HAS A GREAT IMPACT ON THE
FAMILIES OUTSIDE FROM OUR
PROGRAM BENEFITS TO FAMILIES AS
WELL IN OUR GOAL IS TO REALLY
KEEP THOSE. KEEP THOSE FIRST
RESPONDERS THEY TO COME TO WORK
ON A- BASIS. MENTAL HEALTH IS TO
THE SEARCH OF WITH THIS FIRST.
AND- WE WANT TO CONTINUE DOING
THE WE KNOW THAT- WE HAVE TO
SEPARATE. SERVE OTHERS BUT WE
HAVE TO SERVICE FROM THE THAT WE
HELP YOU WILL WE COME TO. MUCH
OF THE- FOR OUR- RESPONDERS IN
TRAINING. BOB IT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT MENTAL HEALTH IT'S
NOT MANDATORY. IT'S NOT
MANDATORY TRAINING SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT A LOT OF TIMES THE
BUDGET- WHEN YOU HAVE BUDGET
DIFFICULTIES. THE PERSON THAT'S
CUT IS NORMALLY ANOTHER.
TRAINING FUNDS SO WE ARE WILLING
LOOKING- WHAT CAN DO TO BETTER
HELP ON. FIRST RESPONDERS ON ALL
LEVELS. SOME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I APPRECIATE. THE CANADIAN
- HELLO COMMITTEE ON THE TOPIC
AND- JUST PROUD TO BE A PER OF
IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE ABOUT
FIVE MORE. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT-
SO IF THERE ARE OTHERS ON THE
LINE I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO BE
BRIEF SO WE CAN GET AS MANY OF
YOU N. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
HEARING YOUR IEAS. OF FOR WHAT
WE CAN DO TO BETTER SUPPORT
NONPROFITS. WE ACTUALLY HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY WELL I SPOKE TO STUDENTS
BUT THANK YOU- WE- I'LL HAVE OF
SENATOR LIMON PROVIDE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
FIRST WELL I'M JUST EXCITED THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO DO THIS I THINK
THAT EVEN WITH THE PANDEMIC- OUR
SCHEDULES HAVE CHANGED OUR
ABILITY TO DO SELECT HEARINGS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS HAVE
SHIFTED- AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
A REFLECTION OF WHAT SO MANY OF
US- ARE GOING THROUGH- IT'S A
GREAT TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH US
ON THE NUMBER RIVAS ON THIS
ISSUE WHO HAS A FAST IF YOU KNOW
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN THIS AREA
AND- I'M EXCITED THAT BOTH
HOUSES. OF THE LEGISLATURE GET
TO REALLY LOOK AT THIS I THINK
THAT THE INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED TODAY AT TO THIS
COMMITTEE IS VERY HELPFUL AND
NOT JUST BECAUSE YOU HEARD BILL
IDEAS COME UP IMMEDIATELY- BUT
CERTAINLY ALSO TO HELP IS
THINKING OF WHAT THE LONG TERM
STRATEGY IS GOING TO BE WE HAVE
A CRISIS SEIZE PUBLIC HEALTH.
EMERGENCIES HAPPEN I'M CERTAINLY
NOT SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN OUR
LIFETIME BUT THEY WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT AND SO-
THINKING LONG TERM IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE DO TO HELP NONPROFITS
AND WHAT WE'RE WE'RE THE STATE
CAN PLAY A ROLE IN CERTAINLY
TALKING TO OUR STATE AGENCIES
THAT'S ANOTHER- AREA WHERE EIGHT
EIGHT THINK THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR THE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO ALSO TALK TO OUR
STATE AGENCIES TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE INTERACTION IS- AROUND-
WORKING WITH OUR NONPROFITS DO
THEY HAVE LEADS ON WHO THEY GO
TO I MEAN SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
GIVEN- IT'S VRY CLEAR THAT
WHILE THERE MIGHT BE FINANCIAL
OPPORTUNITIES. SMALL BUSINESSES
AND NONPROFITS THAT IF SOMEONE
WOULD TO LOOK AT THE APPLICATION
ITSELF IT MIGHT DISCOURAGE THEM
FROM APPLYING IF THEY'RE
NONPROFIT BECAUSE IT SPEAKS TO A
SMALL BUSINESS AND NOT TO A NON
PROFIT SO I HOPE THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION- A
SPECIAL THANKS TO ALL OF OUR
TEAMS THAT I AND STAFF WHO
HELPED PUT THIS TOGETHER AND OF
COURSE EVERY PRESENTER WHO
CHIMED IN TO INFLUENCE. TO THINK
ABOUT- TO HELL BUT THINK ABOUT
HOW WE MOVE THIS FOR TO YOU VERY
. THANK YOU SENATOR YOU MINE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP-
IN THIS COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW I
REALLY APPRECIATE LEARNING FOR
ME- AND SOME OF THE LEGISLATION
THAT YOU. HAVE AUTHORED TO HELP
NONPROFITS IN CALIFORNIA- I LOOK
FORWARD TO ALSO DOING THE SAME
YOU KNOW INTO BEING THE VOICE OF
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. OF YOU KNOW THE
MEMBERS THAT PARTICIPATED TODAY
AND MANY MORE MEMBERS I WANT TO
DO MORE FOR THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S WHY WE
WERE HERE TODAY. UP TO GET THIS
STARTED IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THIS IS GOING TO END THIS IS
JUST THE BEGINNING. OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE- YOU KNOW. HEARING
OF WHAT WE CAN DO- I'M SURE WILL
CONTINUE HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS I WANT TO THANK
CAL NON PROFITS FOR HELPING US
ORGANIZE THIS HEARING AND FOR
PROMOTING IT- TO NONPROFITS
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU TO
ALL OF US THE JOINED. UP US
TODAY FROM EVERYWHERE EVERY
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE-
THANK YOU TO MY TEAM- FOR
ORGANIZING THIS HEARING AND
WITHOUT THEM WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY. I IN SO THANK YU AND
PLEASE CONTINUE IF THERE'S
SOMEONE WATCHING THAT HAS IDEAS
PLEASE REACH OUT TO US WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE HEARINGS
IN THE FUTURE WITH. OTHER
TOPICS- AND YOU KNOW WE REALLY
CARE ABOUT THE NONPROFIT SECTOR.
AND MOST OF ALL WHAT THE STATE
CAN DO TO BETTER SUPPORT THE
NONPROFITS THAT SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.